NUMBER ONE ON IN EDUCATION- SO
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE IN THE
WRONG ROOM THIS IS THE TIME TO
CLIMB OFF THE BUS. THIS IS
POTENTIALLY IT IS OUR-
BEGINNING SESSION SO IT'S R.
OVERVIEW WILL BE TALKING ABOUT
HIS K. TO TWELVE EDUCATION
BUDGET PROPOSAL SO FRESH ASIAN
FUNDED. A COUPLE OF EXTRA ITEMS
ON CHALLENGES AND OF-
INITIATIVE TOWARD THE END SO.
WHY DON'T WE- WELL AS COLD ROLE
WE MIGHT AS WELL ESTABLISHED
QUORUM EVEN THOUGH WE DON'T
PLAN ON TAKING ANY VOTES TODAY.
SENATOR OFF. SENATOR LEYVA.
SENATOR MORALE. OKAY LET'S
START WITH THE FIRST ITEM SIXTY
ONE HUNDRED DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ISSUE NUMBER ONE
OVERVIEW PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT AND K. THROUGH TWELVE
EDUCATION TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET PROPOSALS
PANEL NUMBER ONE IS OUR STATE
SUPERINTENDENT AND THEN WE ALSO
HAVE. A PANEL NUMBER TWO LET'S
START WITH PANEL NUMBER ONE MR
SUPERINTENDENT THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE INVITATION.
TWENTY THREE THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF CONSTRUCTION.
I'M JOINED BY NUMBER OF OUR
TEAM FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WHO
WILL HELP IN ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
MERELY TOMORROW IS OUR CHIEF
DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT STEPHANIE
CORRECTION. FOR RIGHT IS. KNOWS
I WANT OUR- FOLKS BUDGET AND TO
MY LEFT. IS ARE ARE KEY FOR
ISSUES RELATED TO GOV AFFAIRS
AND HAPPY CAPTAIN'S OUR WORK
IDEALLY IN QUICK OF US AND SO.
ABA PLEASE TALK WITH YOU ABOUT
THE STATE DID IN EDUCATION- WE
THINK THAT IT IS A BALANCE IN.
FULL IN. TO ADDRESS OF LOTS
NEEDS AND A COMMISSION AT A
TIME. I THINK OUR STATE STILL
FEELS THAT WE NEED MORE
RESOURCES BUT NONE THE LESS WE
FIT IT'S MOVE. DIRECTION
THOUGHTFUL IT'S WHICH- THE
ESCALATES TO THE LOW CONTROL.
FORMULAE IF YOU IN IN. WANT TWO
DOLLARS FOR TOTAL. SIXTY FOUR
POINT TWO BILLION- THAT
REPRESENTS A CALL OF A TWO
POINT TWO NINE PERCENT- IF YOU
LOOK AT THE HIGHLIGHTS.
HIGHLIGHTED ITEMS IN THE BUDGET
OF SOME OF THE TOP. LINE ITEMS
FOCUSED ON. TREATMENT AND
RETENTION A CHALLENGE AT THE
STATE EXPERIENCES IN MOST
STATES IN OUR NATION- THIS
BUDGET- SPELLS OUT SOME NINE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
PROPOSALS TO SUPPORT TEACHER
RECRUITING AND RETENTION. AND
WHAT THE MOST CRITICAL AREAS
THAT NEED MORE SPECIAL
EDUCATION SPENDING WHICH YOU
THE GENOCIDE FOR DISCUSSION
THIS BUDGET DIVISION SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS OVER TWO YEARS. TO
INCREASE THE BASE RATE SPECIAL
EDUCATION. IT ALSO INCLUDES TWO
AND FIFTY MILLION. FIRST IS THE
PRESCHOOL AGED BUT IN WHO HAVE.
TWO AND- THOSE SERVICES. THE
BUDGET OUTMONEY FOR FUTURE-
NEEDS SO THAT WE'RE PREPARED
OUR STUDENTS FOR THE JOBS OF
TOMORROW AROUND COMPUTER
SCIENCE- SOME- ALMOST TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOCUS AROUND.
COMPUTERS TO PREPARE TEN
THOUSAND K. TWELVE TEACHERS FOR
WORKING COMPUTER SCIENCE. IT
ALSO CALLS OUT SOME SPECIAL
GRANT THAT WILL ALLOW US TO
CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP READY
AS AN ADMIN OF OUR HOPES.
TRAUMA NOW SERVICES BECAUSE OF
THREE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
COMMUNITIES PROGRAMS OF FOR
DISTRICTS IT ALSO CALLS OUT A
NEW PROGRAM AN OPPORTUNITY
GRANTS THEM THAT WOULD HELP
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY- EXPERIENCING
CONDITIONS WERE THEIR STUDENTS
HAVE THE LOWEST PERFORMANCES-
IN THE STATE AND SO I WOULD
MATT THIS IS A HIGH LEVEL
OVERVIEW OF. I'M WE WOULD IT
WOULD SHOULD THERE'S JUST CAN
MANY OUR FIXER A FEELING
CHALLENGES NOW AS WE SPEAK
THEY'RE GONNA MAKE TOUGH
DECISIONS THIS MONTH ABOUT- HOW
IT WORKS TO THEIR BUT THEIR
BUDGET DEFICITS IN STRUCTURAL
DEFICITS. AND THE DOLLAR
CALIFORNIA'S THIRTY NINTH WE'LL
SPENDING AND EVERY EXPERT HAS
WRITTEN THAT WE'VE GOT TO GET
TO A PLACE WHERE WE DO BETTER
AND WHAT WE SPEND ON CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS AND SO WEAK KNOWLEDGE
THAT WILL CHALLENGES BUT WE DID
THIS IT IS THOUGHT OF TRYING TO
BALANCE NEEDS. INTEND TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE- MAN
THIS COMMITTEE IN UP ON HOW WE
SO SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITH THEIR
WITH THEIR BOTTOM LINE NEEDS
FOR ADDRESSING THE RISING COST
OF EDUCATION ESTIMATE THAT AT
THIS AND THEN WE ARE TOO MANY
QUESTIONS MAY HAVE ON THE
COMMITTEE. SEVEN QUESTIONS WHAT
CAN. BRING TEN IT'S GREAT TO
HAVE YOU WITH US I MISS YOU
OVER IN THE ASSEMBLY BUT I
THINK YOU'RE IN A BETTER PLACE
FOR THE CITY CALIFORNIA IF YOU
CENTER YOUR WHAT. TO PUT ON THE
SPOT BUT I GREW. I JUST WANNA
LET YOU KNOW IT'S COMING- WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT TOUGH DECISIONS
BEING MADE AND THAT WERE THIRTY
NINTH IN PER PUPIL SPENDING. DO
YOU HAVE A NUMBER HAVE YOU AS
YOUR OFFICE LOOKED AT WHAT THE
RIGHT NUMBER WOULD BE OR HOW
MUCH MORE MONEY WE SHOULD BE
SPENDING. ON OUR STUDENTS TO
GET US TO WHERE WE NEED. NOT
THIRTY NINTH. I'M THE MOST THE
MOST. REPORTER FROM GETTING
DOWN THE FAX TO PUTS THE NUMBER
IN THE BILLIONS OKAY AT IT IN
ORDER FOR US TO- COMPARED TO
WHAT IT BUT WHAT A STATE LIKE
NEW YORK MAKES IN ITS ALLOCATE
TEN. WOULD MEAN LITERALLY AN
INCREASE. OF I THINK THEY ALSO
POINT OUT THAT IN ORDER TO DO
THAT WE HAVE TO CHANGE THE WAY
WE REVENUE TO THE STATE WE
CAN'T DO THAT WITH CURRENT
REVENUE METRICS THAT HAVE. THE
NEW. TO GENERATE MORE REVENUE
BUT THE NUMBERS IN THE BILLIONS
THAT WE DO A NUMBER YOU HEARING
BEFORE THE END OF THE DAY. ANY
IN THE FUTURE WOULD BE FINE I
JUST IS THE CHAIR OF EDUCATION
I KIND OF WANT TO KNOW WHAT IS
OUR NUMBER WE TRYING TO GET TO
HELP AND THEN WE CAN MAYBE
CREATE A PATH THAT THERE SO
YEAH. CAN BE. MADE IT TOMORROW.
WEAKER THE FOR COUPLE WEEKS
THAT'S FINE THANK YOU IT WILL
IT WILL GET YOUR NUMBER IN AYE
AYE AYE SOME AS PUT IN INCOME
TAX BY THINKING ABOUT WHAT WE
SPENT ON IT. IN LAST YEAR IF
YOU LOOK AT THE CASE FROM. CASE
TWELVE EIGHT AND THEN READY.
YOU'RE PROBABLY WRAPPED IN A-
CASE PIRATE. PERCENT BLESS YOUR
STATE EVEN WITH PASSING PERSON
WE STILL UNABLE TO GET PAST
BEING SOMEWHERE BETWEEN THIRTY
NINETEEN FORTY FIRST IN THE
NATION- WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
THE KIND ECONOMIC DOWNTURN THAT
WE HAVE HAD IN THAT WE MIGHT
EXPERIENCE CALIFORNIA CANNOT
SUSTAIN BILLIONS MORE WITHOUT
CREATING NEW REVENUE STREAM.
YOU HAVE A WORK CREATED THIS
SONG CREATING. ANY FOR THE
STATE WE LOVE TO WORK WITH YOU
TO MADAM CHAIR IN IN IN THE
CAPACITY AS CHAIR OF THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE- AND THIS
COMMITTEE ON LIKE YOU SAY
CREATING THAT PATHWAY TO
GENERATING REVENUE TO. WHICH
NUMBER ONE FARK IT. THIS WAS
NOT MISTER SUPERINTENDENT
IGNORE WE JUST ASK A COUPLE
QUESTIONS- AGAIN AND- NOT TO
PUT YOU ON THE SPOT BUT IN
LOOKING AT THE THANKS FOR THE
HEADS UP. BECAUSE THE THIS MAY
BE OUT OF YEARS OUT OF YOUR
SANDBOX IN IN THE SENSE THAT
IT'S NOT YOUR STATISTIC AND
IT'S NOT YOUR REPORT BUT IN
LOOKING AT. LA THOSE- REPORT-
PROP NINETY EIGHT TEN OTHER
EDUCATION ISSUES. THAT WAS
ISSUED ON FEBRUARY. THERE IS A
STATISTIC IN HERE AND I'M HAPPY
TO ASK KELLY- ABOUT IT WHEN I
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY IN A COUPLE
MINUTES. THAT REFLECTS A WEEK
AT TWO HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
THOUSAND F. T. E. TEACHERS. OR
WE HAD IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN- AND PRESUMABLY WE MAY
HAVE MORE OR LESS BUT- IT'S
RIGHT AROUND THE BALLPARK. AND
ABOUT TWENTY SIX THOUSAND FTP
PRINCIPALS AND OTHER SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS IN THE STATE. SO
TO NINETY FIVE VERSES TWENTY
SIX. IF THAT WHEN WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT OTHER SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS ARE AND AGAIN
IT'S NOT YOUR RECORD BUT IF
THAT STATISTIC HAS ANY VALIDITY
THAN WE IT APPEARS WE HAVE A
RATIO OF. ONE PRINCIPLE OR
SCHOOL ADMINISTRA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR TO. ELEVEN F. T.
E. TEACHERS. WHICH IS A BETTER
RATIO THAN WE HAVE STUDENT A
TEACHER IN THE STATE. ANY IS
THAT AN ANALYSIS OR IS THERE
ANY SIMILAR ANALYSIS THAT GOES
ON WITHIN YOU WERE. A
DEPARTMENT AS TO WHETHER WE
HAVE THE RIGHT NUMBER OF
ADMINISTRATORS VERSUS FOLKS IN
THE CLASS ROOM. CENTER FOR
QUESTION AT JUST THAT WE SPEND
MOST OF OUR TIME THINKING ABOUT
HOW SUPPORT DECATUR'S FROM ALL
BACKGROUNDS DR GREX IS GOING TO
TOUCH ON. THE RATIO BUT WHEN
YOU LOOK AT WHAT THE BUDGET
CALLS FOR AROUND TRAINING. IT
SPLITS THE TRAINING FOR PERFECT
ELEMENT FORTY. AS FOR
ADMINISTRATORS AND IF YOU THINK
ABOUT ALL THE RESEARCH ABOUT
WILL NEED TO DO TO CLOSE. THE
GAP IT TALKS ABOUT WE NEED TO
SUPPORT AB ONE ARMY. AND NOT.
RIGHT AND HAVING I JUST AND
MANY PART OF THE ANALYSIS ABOUT
HOW DRIVE MY MONEY AND THE
CLASS. YOU KNOW STUDENT
SPENDING HOW MUCH MONEY
ACTUALLY FINDS ITS WAY INTO THE
CLASSROOM AND WHETHER THERE.
ARE OPPORTUNITIES TO MAKE IT
JUST CONSIDER AND I'M NOT BEING
CRITICAL I WHICH IS. IT CAUGHT
MY ATTENTION. TODAY AND I
THOUGHT I'D AT. I WOULDN'T TO
ADD ON WHAT ARE SUPER SPOKE
ABOUT YOU AS A FORMER PRINCIPAL
I HAD A SCHOOL SITE OF ABOUT
SIXTY TEACHERS AND I HAD AN
ASSISTANT PRINCIPAL VERY LUCKY
BECAUSE I OVER A HUNDRED
STUDENTS SO WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
EACH INDIVIDUAL SCHOOL FIRE.
AND DISTRICT AND THE NEED TO BE
SIDE SCHOOL HOW. IRV DATE IT'S
REALLY HOW MUCH IS THE RACE
BETWEEN OUR STUDENTS AND OUR-
AND THEY ALSO DISTRICT
ADMINISTRATION SO THERE'S
DIFFERENT LAYERS. OF
ADMINISTRATORS WITHIN THE
SCHOOL IN A COUNTY LEVEL TO
REALLY HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT. TO DETERMINE WHAT IS BEST
RATIO BECAUSE IT'S REALLY HARD.
PINPOINT IT WHEN YOU HAVE
DIFFERENT CONTEXT AND
DEMOGRAPHICS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WITH OUR BEST. HAVE IT
THE STATE ON THAT IT TO
BENCHMARK WHAT. RELY IT'S NOT A-
FIXED. RATE PRESUMABLY ANY
OTHER ENTERPRISE YOU HAVE
MANAGER SUPERVISORS IN THOSE
TWO ASSISTANT ASSISTANCE
SUPERVISION AND THEN YOU HAVE
THE PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY. DO THE
WORK IN. AND THE WORKERS ARE
CERTAINLY VALUABLE IN THE
PROCESS AND- UNDOUBTEDLY NEED
TO BE THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME
OVER SEND SOME TO PROVISION BUT
IN THE EDUCATIONAL. ANY STUDY
IN A COMPETENT THE RIVER DONE.
WHAT ARE IN PERHAPS BUT THEY
SHOULD BE IN EVERY. I DON'T.
THINK ABOUT THE RATE. PRINCE
PERSIST SURE OR DISTRICT
DIMINISH. AS A WHOLE I DO KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF STUDIES AROUND
PRINCIPLE ACTIVE WITH AND WHY.
THEY MEAN TO BE IN A PRINCIPLE.
THAT THEY ARE PUTTING. BUT IS
THIS. MANY CPAS STUDY AGAIN I'M
NOT BE CRITICAL JUST WANNA A AS
THE I THOUGHT IT WAS SORT OF AN
INTERESTING- DATA POINT.
DEPENDING ON HOW WE DEFINE SOME
OF THOSE TERMS IS THAT YOUR
WILL LOOK DEEPER INTO THAT AND
PROVIDE YOU WITH MORE
INFORMATION. OUTSIDE OF THIS
HEARING THAT I WILL IS WE'RE
TALKING. I'M MY WIT'S
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS WHERE THERE
ARE AN ASSISTANT PRINCIPALS.
AND NOT THE FEEDBACK THAT I OFF.
FROM THE PRINCIPAL AND FROM THE
PRINCIPAL STAFF IS THAT THE
PRINCIPAL JUST PULLED IN SO
MANY DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS. THAT
THERE OFTEN IS NOT SOMEONE ELSE
WHO CAN PROVIDE SUPPORT TO THE
TEACHERS AND TO THE STAFF ON
CAMPUS WHEN THERE'S AN
EMERGENCY. WHEN THERE'S ANY FEW
AND IT WAS A PRETTY AWAY FOR IN
THE THING WE WANT. THE
INSTRUCTION PETER WAS COACHING
IS PUTTING. AND I'M WE'RE
CERTAINLY INTEREST IN WHAT UP
REPORTS LIFTING UP WILL LOOK IN
IT I SUSPECT THAT THE- IS ON
THIS CAMPUS YEAH. I SUSPECT THE
ISSUE IS OF THE SCHOOL CAMPUS
YES SIR AND THE QUESTION IS
WILL DOING WHAT THOSE PEOPLE
ARE DOING WHO ARE. JUST ABOVE
THE SCHOOL. SURE HELLO. AND
THAT IS THE YOU ADDED I ISIS
WHEN WE DIG YOU DIG AND THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO FIND. OUT
I'M SHE THAT THIS PURPOSES LEAN
AND MEAN DOWN THERE. DID ME TO
SUGGEST THERE WAS ANYTHING THAT.
IS LEVELS IN THE EDUCATION
SYSTEM ABOVE THE SCHOOL CAMPUS
HERE IT TO THE EXTENT THAT YOU
DO LOOK INTO IT I WOULD ASK
THAT YOU LOOK INTO THAT AS WELL
JUST TO SEE BECAUSE IT ALL
COMES OUT OF THE- QUE.
EDUCATION YES YEAH THE STATE
SURE THAT WE GET THE BEST BANG
FOR OUR BUCK AND DRIVE THE MOST
A DOWN IN THE CLASSROOM WHERE
OUR STUDENTS ARE ACTUALLY BEING
EDUCATED NOW THAT'S NOT TO SAY.
THE FOLKS TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE
AND CURRICULA OAKS PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE ON HOW TO HOW TO
TEACH AFFECTED IN ALL THAT ARE
NOT EXTRA NEARLY VALUE. SYSTEM
I. IF WE HAVEN'T TAKEN. WE WERE.
AS A DISTRAUGHT I'M AND WE'RE
BUSINESS DAY JUST BECAUSE WE
DID IT THAT WAY SIXTY YEARS AGO
MAYBE WE GOT TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT. AND JUST MAKE SURE THAT.
I'M A STILL A VALID WHICH WE
COULDN'T AGREE WITH YOU MORE
AND WE'RE GONNA LOOK AT EVERY
ASPECT OF HOW WE DELIVER
EDUCATION IN THE STATE WITH THE
BLACK EVERYTHING IS PROVOKING
YOU YOU ARE RIGHT. FOR IN. USE
FORCE. IN SO QUESTION THIS IS
WELL TIMED WE'RE ACTUALLY
LOOKING AT EVERY SINGLE WAY IN
SYSTEM IS ENGAGING HELP
DELIVERY CATION CALIFORNIA WE
GOT THE RIGHT TEAM THE PLACE
OVER HAPPENED IN HIS CASE ABOUT
IT ASK A QUESTION ABOUT THE-
BUDGET. RELIES TO GO NOT SURE
BY. BUT THERE MONEY THERE'S MY
OF WAITED OPPOSED BE
APPROPRIATED FOR THINGS LIKE
OPPORTUNITY GRANTS COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS ISN'T ONE TIME MONEY
AND IN SPECIAL EDUCATION- NOT
TO SUGGEST THAT THAT MONEY THAT
THOSE ISSUES ARE NOT- EXTRA
UNDER IMPORTANT AND THAT THE DO
NOT DOES. MONEY DID AT THEM.
LOUIS LET ME BACK UP ONE OF THE
CRITICISMS FOR THE SUGGESTIONS
IS THAT THERE IS A LACK OF.
SPECIFIC GOALS AND OBJECTIVES
ATTACHED TO EACH OF THESE
PROGRAMS. AND GIVEN THAT YOU
ACTUALLY GET ANYTHING OF VALUE
OR OF ANY SIGNIFICANT VALUE OUT
OF A ONE TIME EXPENDITURES TO
HOW HOW DO WE ATTACH. GOALS
OBJECTIVES MILESTONES TO THESE
TO THIS ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
THESE PROGRAMS. SO THAT WE CAN
EVALUATE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE EXPENDITURE AT THE END OF
THE YEAR. WHEN THE NEXT TIME WE
HAVE ABOUT A BUCKET OF MONEY
THAT WE THINK IS GOING TO BE
THERE. BEYOND THE YEAR. WE KNOW.
WHEN WE PICK UP A HANDFUL OF IT
WHERE TO PUT IT IS THAT A FAIR
QUESTION IS A GREAT QUESTION
AND MR CUEVAS IS- READY TO TALK
SOME WORK THAT WEIRD PARTMINER
FINANCE ALLOW HOUSE OF THOSE
PLANS WILL WORK- HEY THIS SAID.
THE GOVERNOR LAID OUT SOME OF
THE PROGRAMS LIKE THE COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS PROGRAM. HE TALKED
ABOUT THE TWO DOZEN DISTRICTS
THAT EXISTS IN THE STATE WERE
KIDS LIVE IN THE HIGHEST RATES
OF POVERTY. DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO POTENTIAL TEACHERS- THERE'S
RITUAL SEGREGATE AND IT IS NO.
ACCIDENT THOSE ARE THE DISTRICT
HAVE I ALSO WISH TO WRAP. OUR
CHEAP MAKE. AND SO- WHAT WE'RE
DOING TO WORKING WITH. KNOW HOW
TO MAKE THAT GRANT PROGRAM BE
SET UP WE CAN MOVE THOSE
RESOURCES THE DISH QUICKLY OUT
WE HAVE WAYS FOR THERE TO BE
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES BUILT
IN FOR REPORTING. ON THE
IMPACTS OF THAT WORK SO IT WAS
TO BUILD INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT
THERE'S MONEY AVAILABLE. YOU
HAVE A EXIST STRUCTURE. THE
FINAL THE DOWN TO THE PLACE
THAT. CAN MAY THE MOST IMPACT I
DON'T KNOW THE GOVERNOR OUR
OFFICES MADE ANY KIND OF
STATEMENTS THAT BECAUSE THESE
ARE FUN THIS TIME THEY'RE GONNA
BE FUNDED YOU YEAR. FOR NOW
WE'RE FOCUSED ON. DOLLARS SPENT
WILL NOW AND THAT THE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE DOLLARS.
AND REPORTS ON THE END. ON THAT
THEY HAVE. ON PROVEN EXPERIENCE
ARRESTED. WILL COMMUNITIES GO
FOR IS A IS A DAY PERFECT
EXAMPLE AS I REMEMBER. AND I'M
NOT. CERTAINLY NO THE EDUCATION
BURDEN THIS FOR. THERE ARE STE
IS IT THAT A THAT THE SCHOOLS
AT LEE HAS AN IMPACT IN THOSE
AREAS WHERE IT IS ON THE GROUND
IN I RIGHT YES YOU WANT TO ADD
TO THIS IS ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
SIR THAT YOU. WE ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING WITH OUR- OUR COLLEAGUE
FIELD ABOUT WHAT WHAT WOULD BE.
WHICH WHEN TAKEN COMMITTEE
SCHOOLS AND SO LEAN ON V. THE
FOLKS ARE UP ON THE FIELD
GIVING US SOME REAL TIME
FEEDBACK AS TO YOU KNOW WHAT'S
NEEDED IN TWENTY TWO MOVING
FORWARD. AND SO I ALREADY HAVE.
CONVERSELY MEANS WORKING VERY
CLOSE WITH THE IT. THE WHEN A
FINANCED THROUGH THE TRAILER.
PROCESS SORT OF THAT. MORE OF
THESE MORE THE- ISSUE THAT YOU
JUST RACER I. HOW DO WE- AFFECT
AND IF IT LONG STATE AS
SUPERINTENDENT THERE IS NO
PROPER SET THE MONEY'S BE
THERE. A YEARS OUT OUR HOPE
ABILITY STRUCTURE PLAY NOW.
YOUR WHEN THE TIME COMES WILL
CAN. THE ISSUE A AND
OPPORTUNITY TO AND MORE FUNDING
FOR IT WE HAVE IT SOME OF STAKE
IN GROUND. THAT SHOWS THAT THE
PER WORK THAT THE FUNDS THAT
WERE INVESTED. WERE WISELY STE
AND MAKING THE FOR INVESTMENT
IF OPPORTUNITY ARISES. IF
NOTHING ELSE AT LEAST WE AT
LEAST HELPED OUR COMMUNITIES
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT. BUILD OUT
A CANISTER SURE THAT THE USE
MOVED OVER. ARE PRESIDENT
EDUCATE THERE'S ALONG THE WAY.
I WILL. TO MORE THOUGHT OR DO
THOUGHT IT WOULD HAVE ADDITION
SAW. TO HOW WE STRUCK. OF THIS
OF. AND I NEED TO GO THE
BETWEEN WHAT IT IS IT'S ABOUT
BILLION BILLION TO. OF ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR PROGRAMS AND VERY
OTHER. ACT THESE GIVE. STRESSOR
THAT ARE EXISTING CASE THROUGH.
TWELVE AT TODAY A AND- I SURE.
SIX THIS ARE. A WE YOU TURN
GOING TO BE UNDER PRESSURE HERE
AS WE CONSIDER THE BUDGET AND
WE MAKE DECISIONS AND TRIAGE
WHAT WE DO. TO DIRECT THIS
MONEY FOR THIS MONEY. TO A
LONGER RANGE PROGRAM EXTENDING
OVER A LONGER PERIOD OF TIME TO
BUY. FINANCIAL RELIEF TO
DISTRICTS WHETHER IT'S IN THE
FORM OF. PENSION BY DOWN
PENSION OBLIGATION BY DOWNS OR
SPECIAL EDUCATION. FUNDING OR
OTHER AREAS WHERE. THE
DISTRICTS ARE UNDER PRESSURE
WITH RESPECT TO THEIR GENERAL
FUND AND SO WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THESE ONE
TIME EXPENDITURES THESE ONE
TIME PRO. GRAMS THAT SET UP
SORT OF ON A ONE TIME BASED.
RIGHT I. OTHER THEN YOU KNOW
THOSE FUNDED SO I'LL FORWARD TO
WORK WITH YOU ALL ON THIS ISSUE
AS WE MOVE FURTHER DOWN THE
LINE IN THE BUDGET PROCESS. AND
DEAL WITH THE OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE
UNDOUBTEDLY GOING TO JOIN US AT
THE TABLE TO HAVE A SAY IN. IN
THIS PROCESS SO. ASSEMBLY I
JUST WANT TO PUBLICLY REGISTER
MY SUPPORT FOR COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS I THINK WE ASK SO MUCH
MORE OF OUR SCHOOLS OF OUR
TEACHERS IF WE CAN CREATE THESE
COMMUNITY HEALTH AT THE SCHOOLS
I THINK IT BY THE BED WITH A
LITTLE BIT OF RELIEF KNOW NOT
HAVING TO BE THE MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDER. KIDS ARE DISCO PUNK.
AND THAT ALL JUST. OUR AND FOR.
JUST ONE REGISTER MY SUPPORT
AND SAY IN WAY THAT I CAN BE.
ON A YOU WANNA COME ON TO THE I
WE SET SOME UP THERE HAPPY TO
WITH THAT BUT I THINK MIGHT BE
NEW IF THINKING OF OUR SCHOOL
I'M SO USED A LOT FROM WHEN I.
FOR TWENTY. IS A FORWARD. THANK
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE
CHAIRMAN WAS MAKING THE POINT
THAT THE- SCHOOLS. ACTUALLY
HAVE. THERE'S RESEARCH. THAT
PROVEN THAT IT ACTUALLY. AND
ACT. BEFORE SENSE OF WE'RE-
YOUR STATE AND THEN YOU.
LEADERSHIP HERE WE WILL. WE
HONEST. THAT THE CONVERSE.
ABOUT OF THE ONCE I INVESTMENTS
HAVE TO. BE THE LARGER. CON ALL
THE THINGS THAT ISSUE. PENSION
PENSION ON THE- AMONG THE THAT
WE HAVE TAKEN WE DO HAVE A WE
HAVE CREATE ALL A THAT IS FOCUS
ON THE ISSUE OF PENSION HAVE
WITH THIS FOR ABOUT THEY CAN
ADDRESS SPENT NOT BE GAVE AND
CONNECT TO IT MIGHT IN THE
STATE FOR DOING. FOR TO STAY
INTO FOR THE ABOUT THAT. TO BE
CLEAR YOU UNDERSTAND CONCERN IS
NOT WITH THE VALIDITY OF THE
PROGRAM BUILT A ONE TIME NATURE
THE FIRST SO IF WE DID AS A- AS
A SENATOR PERCENT. HEAVEN
FORBID WE THE OTHER IS A
LEGISLATURE A- WHAT WHAT
PROGRAMS OF TENER EVER MANY
THERE ARE HAVE MORE THAN OTHER
NOT TO ANY OF THE- NO OUR VALUE
WHAT'S TO SAY INSTEAD OF THREE
HUNDRED AS A ONE TIME. FUNDING
ITEM WE DON'T DO NINE HUNDRED
BILLION THEN ON GO FUNDING OR
WHATEVER TO CONTINUE THE
PROGRAM BUT HARD TO ESTABLISH A
COMMUNITY SCHOOL ONE TIME. THIS
NO NO WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
IT NEXT YEAR SO. YOU CAN HARPER
BECAUSE AT CREE AN IS. YOU
CAN'T BUILD SO BECAUSE THAT
CREE AN AGE. SO YOU'RE SETTLING
AS TO WHAT YOU DO YOU'RE
LIMITED IT SEEMS TO ME THE
STAFF YOU HAVE IN THE ASSET YOU
HAVE AND TRY TO MAKE IT A
LITTLE BETTER AND MAYBE THAT'S
THE SOLUTION BUT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE THE COVERAGE SAID. CAN
I LOOK FORWARD. AT MY PER. TO
HELLO. WE LIVE WHERE YOU AND I
CAN AND I THIS CAN ARE GRAY
PLACE TO DO IT THANK FOR YOUR-
CONSIDER GUESS THAT. YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANKS FOR JOINING US. FELLOW
NUMBER TWO. YOU KNOW YOU ARE.
YEAH. I COULD ASK YOU ALL TO
IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR THE
RECORD- LET'S SEE WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE ANOTHER. PARTICIPANTS
ARE EVER GOING TO HAVE YOU
IDENTIFY YOURSELF FOR THE
RECORD STARTING TO MY LEFT
YOU'RE RIGHT. MA'AM THAT YOU.
BUT BUT THEY YOU AGAIN I AM
CHRISTIAN RIGHT THIS EDUCATION.
AT THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. GOOD MORNING LISA
RESIDENTS GIVE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. A GROUP
BROUGHT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. CAN COUPON
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. YEAH MAY NOT ASK ANY
QUESTIONS THEY HAVE EXPERTS IN
FRONT OF ME OKAY WHO WANTS TO
START. I'LL START AGAIN WE CAN
PRESENT YOU WITH APARTMENT A
FINANCESO YOU SHOULD HAVE
RECEIVED A ONE PAGE HANDOUT.
ALL THAT HAND OUT OF THE FIRST
FIGURE IS JUST A- OVERVIEW OR
SUMMARY OF THE PROPOSITION
NINETY A GUARANTEE OVER THE
THREE YEAR BUDGET WINDOW- AND
THEN YOU'RE TO LAYS OUT THE
GOVERNORS OF FOR THE TWENTY.
FIRST YOU TO LAYS OUT A- THIS
SPINACH TO INCLUDE IN THE NURSE
FOR A PROPOSAL FOR K. TWELVE ON
THE BACK YOU'LL SEE A DETAILED
LIST OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
SENATORS INCLUDING AND THIS WAS
ALL THIRD TO BEGIN WITH BUDGET
AGAIN IS THAT WITH THE OF ANY.
EARLY STRONG A ON AS REFLECTED
IN FIGURE ON OVER THREE
EUROPEAN WERE UP THAT BOTH
REVENUES AND TAXES SEE A
SIZEABLE IN. AGAIN AS WE'VE
BEEN SEEN AND THEY'RE OUT
PERFORM THIS. AND ANOTHER ON
PROP NINETY FIVE TO CUT NOTE IS
AGAIN AVERAGE TEN IN A ROW.
WORK CONTINUING TO SEE AT THE
IN THE AREAS. AND THIS IS
REALLY TO MAJOR FOR ONE NECK
NECK MY GRAY OUT OF STATE OF
ALSO OUR BIRTH RATES. IN HAVE
BEEN DROPPING. SO AS A RESULT
OF THOSE THREE FACTORS YOU'LL
SEE THAT PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT OVER THE THREE YEAR
PERIOD WILL BE IN A TEST ONE
YEAR. IN ADDITION A YOU'LL SEE
THAT OF ANY THE INCREASE IN
REVENUES IN PROPERTY TAX. HAS
LED TO AN IN IN THE GUARANTEED
OVER THE THREE YEAR PERIOD SOME
ANTICIPATING A THREE NINE TWO
MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FIVE HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE IN- I'M SORRY EIGHTEEN
AT NINETEEN TWENTY. AND THEN A
TWO POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLAR.
INCREASE IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
OVER OUR OVER THE TO THE-
NINETEEN TWENTY. ESTIMATE I'M
ADDITIONAL. SOME IN THAT
POSITIVE TO THE PUBLIC SCHOOL
STABLE. ACCOUNT A LAST YEAR I
WAS WE NOTED WE HAD ALL OF THE-
REQUIREMENTS IN ORDER TO PUT
THE FIRST DEPOSIT. THROUGH THE
DEPOSIT WAS THREE NINE SEVENTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
NINETEEN TWENTY YEAR. LAST YEAR
AND WERE ESTIMATED TO BE ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION FOR NINETEEN TWENTY.
AND INCREASED HUNDRED FORTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS.
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE REQUIRED TO
MAKE A WITHDRAWAL FROM THE
ACCOUNT IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE OF
THIRTY EIGHT MILLION AND AGAIN
THIS IS JUST TO ENSURE THAT
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
RECEIVED. AN ADJUSTMENT FOR
GROWTH AND THEN ALSO IN
INFLATION SCARE. IF SO AGAIN
NOW WILL ALL JUST DISCUSS OF
THE HIGH LEVEL EXPENDITURE FOR
KATE TWELVE I WON'T GO OVER THE
DETAILS BECAUSE I'M SURE WE'LL
HAVE FUTURE HEARINGS ON THIS
BUT SO EVEN THOUGH WE ARE TO
PROJECT CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY TO
GROW- THE STATE'S I'M UP
CONTINUE TO PREPARE FOR AND SIR
THE END STE INSTABILITY OF.
MARKETS AND ALSO. POLITICAL
CLOUT. SO TO THAT IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PLAN BALANCE ATTRACT
ABOUT ON GO INCREASES WITH
SOMEONE TIME INVESTMENTS TO
ALLOW FOR SOME ROOM IN THE
GUARANTEE SHOULD WE NEED TO WE
CAN REDUCE EXPENDITURES WITHOUT
IMPACTING ON PROGRAMS THAT ARE
ONGOING NATURE AT THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. SO WITH REGARD TO
THAT ONGOING EXPENDITURES WE
FOCUSED ON THE LARGEST PROGRAMS
BY BRIGHT PROVIDING- A
STATUTORY COLE OF TWO POINT 29%
TO THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA I'M AND THEN I HAD
TWENTY SIX MY DOLLARS CALL IT
ALL THE OTHER CAT. BETTER IN
PROP NINETY EIGHT. ON ONE OF
OUR LARGEST I'M INVESTMENTS AND
THOUGH THIS MONEY WAS SPENT
YEAR FIRST TO. WAS ON A ONE
TIME BASIS BUT WERE PROPOSING A
SIX HUNDRED FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR INVEST IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION. TO BASE. FORMULA AND
THEN FINE ON ONE TIME NEW TO
WITH THERE'S SIXTEEN DOLLAR
INCLUDED IN THIS BUDGET FOR
ONGOING NUTRITION PROGRAM TO
INCREASE THE REIMBURSEMENT
RATES UP TO THE NEW CHURCH
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM. SO ON
MOVING ON TO ONE TIME
EXPENDITURES. ON THE TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE SPENDING
PLAN- INCLUDE SIGNIFICANT ONE
TIME K. TWELVE AS AS YOU
MENTIONED EARLIER VERY
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS. THIS
REFLECTS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
COMMAND TO IMPROVE
OPPORTUNITIES AND OUTCOMES FOR
EVERY CHILD IN OUR STATE IT
BOUGHT BUT ALSO RECOGNIZING THE
POTENTIAL OF FOR DECLINE AND
WHICH COULD PACK THE IN. THE
PROP NINETY GUARANTEE. THESE
PROPOSALS ARE TARGETED
PROVIDING. AND SUPPORT TO PROBE
AIMED AT CLOSING ACHIEVEMENT
GAP AND ENSURING THAT TEACHERS
AND SCHOOL LEADERS ARE PREPARED
TO- WITH THE TOOLS NECESSARY TO
A- TO A TEACHER CHILDREN AND TO
IMPROVE THEIR OUTCOMES. TO
REFLECT THIS PRIORITY IT
INCLUDES NEARLY NINE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR EDUCATOR
AGREEMENT AND TRAINING.
RESEARCH INDICATES A WELL
PREPARED TEACHER WORK FORCE IS
SIGNIFICANT FACTOR IN
PREDICTING STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT
AND IN CLOSING THE SUCH A GAP
HOWEVER CALIFORNIA HAS
STRUGGLED WITH TRAINING AND
RECRUITING TEACHERS ESPECIALLY
IN OUR KEY SUBJECT AREA MATTERS
AND ALSO IN HIGH NEED AREAS. SO
THE FIRST I'M ART OF THE
TEACHER PROPOSAL THE NINE
HUNDRED MILLION IS REALLY
FOCUSED ON PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT A GROUP IT THAT'S
THREE AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
IS FOR THE- EDUCATOR WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT GRANT SOMETHING YOU
SAW LAST YEAR'S BUDGET IT'S AN
EXTENSION OF THAT ON THE OTHER
FIVE PROPOSAL WE'LL GET INTO IN
DETAIL- BUT- ARE FOCUSED MORE
ON EDUCATE. RECRUITMENT AND
IMPROPER. AND THIS IS NOT ONLY
TEACHER NOT ONLY TEACHERS BUT
ADMINISTRATORS PARA
PROFESSIONALS AND ALL OF THE
OTHER- STAFF THAT. WE NEED IN
OUR SCHOOLS. THE STATE OF MADE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN
VARIOUS EDUCATION PROPOSALS AND
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMALLY OF EIGHT YEARS WHILE
THESE INVESTMENTS ARE PAYING
OFF AND WE'RE STARTING TO SEE
SOME IMPROVEMENTS IN MANY OF
OUR ACHIEVEMENT GAP. AT THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP FOR STUDENTS
WITH EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS AND
THOSE THAT LIVE IN DEEP POVERTY
CONTINUES TO PERSIST SO WHAT
WE'RE DOING TO THIS EDITION TO
THE TEACHER WHICH WE FEEL IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO CLOSING THIS
GAP IN SPECIAL EDUCATION
INVESTMENTS THE BUDGET INCLUDES
TO PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT TARGETED RESOURCES
AND STATES THAT. TO PRESS SOME
OF THE IS THAT WHEN'S THESE
GAPS THE FIRST A PROPOSAL TO
THREE HUNDRED MILLION TO A
OPPORTUNITY GRANTS THIS PROGRAM
WILL TARGET THE STATE'S
HIGHEST- PARTY DISTRICTS WHICH
HAVE THE LOWEST PERFORMING
STUDENTS. IS THERE IN TEN.
INTENT OF GRAY AND INTO.
CONTENTS OF THE- WHICH I TO BE
PH<c.cyan>N THIS. ISSUES THAT WERE</c>
SEEN AND OF THESE. BUT ALSO
PROPOSES THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO ESTABLISH THE
COMMUNITY SCHOOL PARTNERSHIP
GRANT WHICH AGAIN IS A MODEL
THAT HAS BEEN INNOVATIVE AND
HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL THAT WERE
SEEN IN OUR SCHOOLS. NEXT TO
I'D LIKE TO JUST POINT OUT THAT
IN ADDITION TO THE SIX HUNDRED
FORTY FIVE MILLION THERE'S TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION SATISFIED
FOR A PRE SCHOOL. OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION PRESCHOOL EARLY INNER
GEN WHICH WILL GO TO DISTRICTS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY SERVING OUR
SCHOOLS STUDENTS WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS THIS IS SIMILAR IN FACT.
NEARLY SOME ARE IDENTICAL TO
THE GRANTS THAT WE DID LAST
YEAR IN THE SAME THERE'S SOME
SLIGHT VARIATIONS THAT WILL BE
DISCUSSED ON THE NEXT PANEL.
THE WITH. OF ANY OTHER. YOU
KNOW WOULD BE MORE THAN HAPPY
TO. THE BUT I'M SURE THEY CAN
WAIT TO DIFFERENT. BUT IF YOU
ANY. I'LL BE GLAD TO ANSWER.
THANK YOU MA'AM YOU PROBABLY
YOU HEARD MY QUESTIONS OF THE
LAST PANEL JUST TO SORT OF. I
GUESS SET THIS UP BY I. IN
CURIOUS AS TO WHEN WE DECIDE TO
MOVE OUT WITH ONE TIME MONEY IN
VARIOUS PROGRAMS. IF THERE ARE
GOALS AND OBJECTIVES OF THE
SAID THAT ARE SENT OUT AS TO
WHAT WE HOPE TO ACCOMPLISH WITH
THE EXPENDITURE OF MONEY
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY. ALL OF THE
PROGRAMS IN THE LIST THAT I'VE
REVIEWED ARE EXTREMELY VALUABLE
AND THEY ALL HAVE A GROUP OF
STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE
PASSIONATE ABOUT THEM AS- HAVE.
THAT THE- EXPECT SURE WE DON'T
SPEND A LOT OF TIME HERE
THINKING ABOUT THAT AND I THINK
MAYBE. IF WE DON'T DO IT THIS
YEAR ONE IF I'M STILL AROUND IN
THIS YEAR WE'LL DO IT NEXT YEAR
AND TAKE A LOOK BACK. AS TO HOW
WHAT HAPPENED WHEN WE SPENT
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ON ACTS AND SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS AND WHY AND WHAT WE GET
FROM IT SO. I'M THINKING MAYBE
WE OUGHT TO THINK ABOUT THAT AT
THE FRONT END. KNOWING THAT AT
THE BACK AND IF I'M HERE I MAY
BE ASKING QUESTIONS AND I'D
HATE TO SURPRISE ANYBODY WITH
MY QUESTIONS. SO FOR EXAMPLE.
IF THE EDUCATOR WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT GRANT PROGRAM IS AN
EXTENSION. WE HAD IT LAST YEAR.
I RECALL RIGHT. WHAT WHAT
RESULT DID WE GET FROM THE
EXPENDITURE LAST YEAR AND IS IT
TOO EARLY TO ASK THAT QUESTION.
WHICH SOMETIMES IS THE CASE SO
THAT'S QUESTION NUMBER ONE OR
TWO. OR IS THE ISSUE WE DIDN'T
SET UP ANY METRICS TO BEGIN
WITH WITH THREE WITH RESPECT TO
THE PROGRAM. AND I COULD I
COULD GO THROUGH ALL OF THEM.
IN THE ONE TIME EXPENDITURE
CATEGORY AND ASKED THE SAME
QUESTION NOW THIS IS SORT OF
THE OVERVIEW AND WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY LATER TO GET INTO
IT BUT I'M HOPING WHEN WE COME
BACK AND REVISIT SOME OF THESE
SPECIFIC PROGRAMS. EITHER AT
THE TIME THAT WE TAKE A VOTE OR
BEFORE THE WE CONDUCT THAT SORT
OF EXAMINATION BECAUSE MY THE
QUESTION YOU KNOW I CAME OUT OF
THE MILITARY SO. YOU KNOW GETS
MEASURE GETS. AND HOW ARE WE
DETERMINE WHETHER WE'VE ONE WAR
OR LAW. ABOUT WE AGREE WITH YOU
IN WE DO BELIEVE THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF MONEY SPENT IN EDUCATION
OVER MANY YEARS THAT HAVE NOT
HAD THAT FOLLOW UP ON ABOUT
EVALUATIONS AND ACCOUNTABILITY
ALL OF THE ONE TIME INVESTMENTS
THAT YOU SEE HAVE BUILT AND
EVALUATIONS AND ACCOUNTABILITY
INCLUDING THE WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT GRANT WENT OUT LAST
YEAR. ON INCLUDE GOING FORWARD
BUT IT'S BUT IT'S VERY. STATION
TO MAKE SURE THAT WHAT. YOU
WE'RE TRACKING WHERE WHERE.
WHAT WORKS IF. WORTHY OF
INVESTMENTS AND WHAT DOESN'T.
THERE'S ALSO A DEEP COMMITMENT
TO CONNECT ALL OF THESE LESSONS
LEARNED FROM THESE PROGRAMS.
CONNECT THEM TO THE STATE
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT SO FOR
INSTANCE IN THE OPPORTUNITY
GRANTS THE COMMUNITY SCHOOL
MODEL THAT THIS IS WORKING
WELL. ON THE COUNTIES WILL BE
INVOLVED IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THESE PROGRAMS AND ABLE TO HELP
OTHER SCHOOLS THAT MAY NOT
NECESSARILY RECEIVE THE GRANT.
BUT SIMILAR PULLS IT JUST. IS
WHAT. BE OUT OF. WORK WITH
BUDGETS TO SEE WHAT WE HAVE
DEEP AND FILES BUT NONE OF THAT
IS IN ANALYSIS I'VE READ AND I
DON'T. IT'S THE LA REPORT. SO
IF SOMEONE. GOALS IN OF.
ATTACHED THIS ONE EXT. PLAN IN
THESE PROGRAMS. MOTHER MUST BE
KEEPING HIM SOMEWHERE. THAT'S
THE BILL AROUND THE FLOOR. I
SEEN THEM AND I LIKE TO THEM
FOR. IN THE WORK FORCE
DEVELOPMENT GRANT PROGRAM.
DRESS WORKFORCE SHORTAGES HIGH
NEED SUBJECT THERE IS NO
QUESTION. THAT WE NEED THAT WE
NEED YOU KNOW. STEM STEAM BUT
IT. TERM YOU WANT TO USE
TEACHERS WE NEED THEM IN. MORE
SOME AREAS A IN A SPECIAL ED
INSTRUCTORS AND SPECIALISTS.
BUT WHEN WE PUT A HUNDRED AND
NINETY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
GRANT PROGRAM. WHAT ARE WE
EXPECTING TO SEE AT THE END OF
TWELVE MONTHS OR EIGHTEEN OR
TWENTY FOUR. IS IT. A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY FIVE NEW TEACHERS.
HUNDRED AND FIFTY RETRAIN
TEACHERS. SINCE I'M NOT AN
EDUCATION SPECIALISTS SOMEBODY
CAN TELL ME EITHER NOW OR WHEN
WE GET TO THE MORE DETAILED
CONVERSATION THAT'S NOT HOW WE
MEASURE THIS I'M OKAY WITH THAT
THEN TO ME HOW EDUCATORS
MEASURE THIS. THIS BODY MUST
MEASURE IT. AND DETERMINE
WHETHER THEY'VE DONE A GOOD JOB
OR A BAD JOB AND I'M JUST NOT
SEEING. THE SORT OF ANALYSIS.
COME FORWARD AND THE ONE TIME
EXPENDITURES SO AGAIN STRAW
NEARLY VALUABLE PROGRAMS. POSES
MY FORMER MAYOR INTERESTS USED
SAY C° TO THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR STEPPING OUT ON SOME OF
THESE ISSUES I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT WE DO SOME DEEP
THINKING BEFORE WE START GOING
THE CHECKBOOK UP. AND THE
SIGNATURE AROUND. HE CERTAINLY
CHECK THAT COMMENT WOULD LIKE
TO WORK WITH YOU IN YOUR STAFF
MAKING SURE THESE PROP HAVE
TYPE OF THE IN MATTER THAT
WOULD. MEET YOUR- PERFECT.
THEIR LIVING QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU FOR BEING AND JOINING US
TODAY. OUR SPECIAL. THE I THINK
YOU SAID THAT WE ARE GOING TO
COME UP WITH A NEW FUNDING
FORMULA FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
HAVE YOU COME UP THAT FORMULA
IF YOU HAVE WHAT IS THAT LOOK
LIKE. SO I THINK THE NEXT PANEL
GOING TO DISCUSS THIS MORE
DETAILED AT THE BASE FOR IT.
REALLY IS THE CENTER SPACE
FORMULA AND JUST THE BASE OF
THE FORMULA WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
ALSO BUILDING AND GROUP AND
STUDY AND TO DETERMINE WHAT THE-
NO FOR WHICH- ANY. ON'T OF IT.
BUT THIS. WHICH TO FOR FUTURE I
JUST ABOUT FORMULA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM WHO'S NEXT ANY
AND SENATOR CAN COUPON WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
I'LL BE SPEAKING FROM A HANDOUT
THE SERGEANT JUST PASSED AROUND.
YOU KNOW A PROPOSITION EIGHT
DETERMINED BY ONE OF THREE
TESTS IN THE STATE CONSTITUTION
AND AS YOU HEARD THE
ADMINISTRATION SAY. I TEST ONE
IS THE OPERATIVE TEST OVER THE
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TO TWENTY
TWENTY ONE PERIOD. AND THAT
SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE IT MEANS
THAT TO THE EXTENT THERE ARE
ANY CHANGES IN GENERAL FUND
REVENUE. THE GUARANTEE WOULD
INCREASE OR DECREASE ABOUT
FORTY CENTS FOR EACH DOLLAR OF
HIGHER LOWER REVENUE. IT ALSO
MEANS THAT IF THERE ARE ANY
CHANGES IN PROPERTY TAX
ESTIMATES THOSE AT A DOLLAR FOR
DOLLAR AFFECT ON ANTI. TO
TRYING TO PAY ONE OF OUR HAND
OUT. AS YOU HEARD ALREADY THE
GUARANTEE. IN A NINETY IS A
THREE HUNDRED TO ME. THAT'S
MAINLY DUE TO HIGH PROPERTY TAX
FROM. THE NINETEEN TWENTY
GUARANTEE IS UP FIVE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTEEN MILLION. THAT'S
MAINLY DUE TO HIGHER GENERAL
FUND REVENUE. I'M WITH MOVING
AHEAD TO PAGE TWO I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION GIVE YOU A GOOD
OVERVIEW OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE GUARANTEE. EIGHTY FOUR
BILLION UP TWO AND A HALF
BILLION OVER THE NINETEEN
TWENTY LEVEL. I ONE POINT TO
HIGHLIGHT IS THAT THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE AND THIS PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT RESERVE ARE FAIRLY
CLOSELY CONNECTED. SO TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE GUARANTEE IS
HIGHER BY MAY. WE HAVE TO
DEPOSIT MORE MONEY INTO THE
STATE'S RESERVE IF THE
GUARANTEE IS LOWER WE WOULD
PROBABLY MAKE A LARGER
WITHDRAWAL FROM THERE IS IF. I
HAD TO PAY THREE. WE THINK THE-
DESK. OF CHEN FUND RATHER. I
READ. AT MINISTRY IS FAIRLY
CLOSE TO A AND EIGHTY NINETEEN.
A LITTLE BIT HIGHER IN. TO A
LITTLE BIT LOW. IN TWENTY TWO
ONE. BUT THE THREE YEAR PERIOD
OUR ESTIMATES LESS THAN A
HUNDRED. DIFFERENT SO WHICH OF
THE IDENTICAL FOR A- STATE
BUDGET PERSPECTIVE. WE ARE
CONTINUING TO MY- SOME RISKS TO
STATE. AT ACTIVE A SLOW. IN JOB
GROWTH ISN'T AS FAST AS IT WAS
PREVIOUSLY- BUT BASED ON WHAT
WE NOTED NO TODAY WE THINK THE
GOVERNOR HAS PUT FORWARD A
REASONABLE ESTIMATE OF STATE
REVENUE AND THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE. THE MINISTRY IS
ABOVE US ABOUT SIX HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE MILLION ON THEIR
PROPERTY TAX ESTIMATES. I
YOU'LL BE HEARING MORE FROM US
ABOUT THAT I WITHIN THE NEXT
FEW DAYS. BUT I THINK- WE
ANTICIPATE THAT THOSE
DIFFERENCES WILL NARROW BY THE
TIME WE DO OUR NEXT OUTLOOK IT
MAY. TURNING TO PAGE FOR. ALL
OF THE INCREASES IN THE
GUARANTEES SUPPORT ABOUT FOUR
BILLION IN NEW SPENDING FOR
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
OF SPECIFIC PROPOSALS ARE
DIVIDED ABOUT EVENLY BETWEEN
NEW ONE TIME SPENDING AND YOU
I'M GOING SPENDING. FOR K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS NO ALL THE ON IN
FUNDING THIS TO SUPPORT THE TWO
POINT 29% COST OF LIVING IN.
WENT ONE TIME. IS FOR THAT
COULD DIMINISH AROUND EDUCATION
WORK FORCE. OR FOR IMPROVING
ACADEMIC OUTCOMES AT CERTAIN
LOW PERFORMING SCHOOLS. PAGE
FIVE IS JUST A RUNDOWN OF THIS
THE SPECIFIC PROPOSAL THEY
WON'T COVER THAT ANY ANY DETAIL
YOU GET INTO ALL OF THOSE LATER
THIS YEAR. I TURNING TO PAGE
SIX. I WITHIN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET HAS SOME POSITIVE
COMPONENTS AND- I THINK MR SURE
YOU ARTICULATED THEM VERY WELL-
THERE'S A MIX. OF A ONE TIME AN
ONGOING PROPOSALS- WE THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT
GIVES YOU A LITTLE BIT OF A
BUDGET CUSHION IN CASE THE
MINIMUM. THE CLIENT. HEY WHAT'S
A LOT LESS JUST. TO ADJUST ONE
TIME SPENDING TO ADJUST ONGOING
A- ON GOING PROGRAM CAL CFF.
THE BUT DRAWS ATTENTION JUST.
WHO'S MANY JUST TO WITH
ACHIEVEMENT GAP. AND MANY
DISTRICTS HAVE TO FINE TEACHERS
CERTAIN SOME AREA. ARE TURNING
TO PAGE SO I THINK US. YOU'VE A
PARTICULAR SOME OF I CAN ARE A
WE THINK THAT SOME OF THE-
WOULD NOT ADDRESS THE UNDER.
CAUSES OF THE PROBLEMS THE GOV
IS CAN. OUR CONCERN THAT SOME
THE OLD NOT ALLOW WITH THE
STATE'S SIX EFFORT TO A- UP
ACHIEVE AND- WORK FIRST HIS.
AND WE CAN ABOUT THE GROUP THAT
HAVE VERY MUCH DETAIL A HOW THE
FOR WOULD BE YOU. IF THE TO
EVALUATE IT. GET ME SIR THAT
THE BUDGET DOES NOT PROVIDE.
ALL THAT MUCH IN FISCAL RELIEF
FOR DOES. DISTRICTS ARE FACED
HIGHER COST PER FOR VARIOUS
SOURCES PER HIGHER PENSION AND
GROWTH AND STUFF EDUCATION
COSTS. AT THE BUDGET DOES THAT
COLA BUT GIVEN ALL OF PRESSURE
WITHIN DISTRICTS ARE LOOKING AT.
IT BUT SITUATION NEXT YEAR.
FIND TURNING TO PAGE EIGHT. AM
AND OUR RECOMMENDATIONS WOULD
RECKON YOU CAN TO BUILD A
BUDGET THAT RELY ON A MIX OF
ONE TIME AN ONGOING SPENDING.
IT DOESN'T NECESSARILY HAVE TO
BE THE EXACT SAME ACCESS WHAT
THE GOVERNOR PUT FORWARD BUT
THAT IS A REASON STARTING POINT.
I WOULD RECOMMEND FUNDING. WILL
GOVERNOR'S ONE TIME PROPOSALS
FOR. SO ON THE ONES THAT
DIRECTLY ADDRESS THE UNDERLYING
PROBLEMS AND HAVE CLEAR
OBJECTIVES AND SPENDING
REQUIREMENTS. WE RECOMMEND YOU
REJECT MOST OF THE GULF.
THERE'S OTHER ONE TIME
PROPOSALS. IF YOU WERE TO ADOPT
ALL OF OUR RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
WOULD FREE UP ABOUT A BILLION
DOLLARS INSIDE. NINE FOR OTHER
PRIORITY. AND FINE WE AND YOU
THE FREED UP FUNDING GROUP DISK
RELIEF. YOU'VE GOT VARIOUS WAYS
YOU CAN GO UP THAT. WE THINK
THE MOST PROMISING OPTION WOULD
BE TO HELP PAY DOWN DISTRICT
FUNDED PENSION LIABILITIES THAT
WOULD BOTH. FISCAL HEALTH OF
THE CONCERT. IT COULD ALSO
DISTRICTS WITH TO LEAP ON
ASSISTING BASIS. IN ADDITION TO
PAYING DOWN ABILITY WE THINK
YOU COULD COME USING A PORTION
OF THAT PENSION FUNDING REDUCED
AND COSTS. AND TWENTY ONE.
RIGHT NOW DISTRICT PENSION
COSTS ARE SCHEDULED TO GO UP
THE NEXT YEAR THEN COME DOWN A
LITTLE BIT THE FOLLOWING YEAR.
JUST COULD USE ABOUT THREE
MILLION TO SOME WITHOUT THAT
PENSION COSTS TOM AND ALLOW
COST TO GO MOST MORE SLOWLY AND
STEADILY OVER THE NEXT FEW
YEARS. I THAT'S REALLY OUR TAKE
ON THE PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
PACKAGE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. WELL THEY'RE LIVING
QUESTIONS TO. GO AHEAD THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. OF THE COMING
FROM THE LABOR. I ALWAYS IT'S A
GREAT IDEA TO PAY DOWN PENSION
OBLIGATIONS SO THAT PEOPLE WILL
HAVE A SECURE RETIREMENT. DO
YOU HAVE A NUMBER. OF THAT YOU
WOULD SUGGEST TO US- ON PAYING
DOWN. I MEAN I WOULD WE DO LAST
YEAR. FIFTY MILLION HELLO LAST
YEAR WAS A WAS A PAYMENT FOR
BOTH OF THE PENSION SYSTEMS
BOTH CHARACTERS IN CALPERS A
LITTLE OVER THREE BILLION AND
IT WAS SUPPOSED TO PAY DOWN OF.
THE UNFUNDED LIABILITIES PLUS
IMMEDIATE RELIEF OVER THE NEXT
TWO YEARS SO IF YOU'RE
SUGGESTING WE PAY DOWN THERE
UNFUNDED LIABILITY THIS YEAR
BUT DO YOU HAVE A NUMBER. IF
YOU REJECTED ALL OF THE IF YOU
ADOPTED ALL OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS YOU HAVE ABOUT
A BILLION. YOU COULD ALSO YOU
KNOW WE WE'VE HEARD THAT
THERE'S INTEREST IN USING SOME
NON PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT AS
WELL I'VE YOU CAN ONLY DO THAT.
KIND OF DEPENDS ON THE TRADE
OFF TO BETWEEN DATA NEEDS TO
PROGRAM. MISSION THANK YOU.
AFTER THEY WERE PROPOSED THAT
BILLION AND THEN USE A PENSION
PAID OUT GOT IT AND HOW MUCH I
KNOW IT WOULD VERY BASS DOES TO
SCHOOL DISTRICT BUT HOW MUCH DO
YOU HAVE ANY AYE PER WERE MAYBE
HOW MUCH MONEY THIS COULD FOR
UP FOR SCHOOL THIS. IT DEPEND
ON HOW YOU GIVE IT UP. BUT
SPECIFIC IN HERE IT COULD BE A-
OTHER ELITE SAMPLE IF YOU THAT
FOR MILLION SET ASIDE. THAT'S
THREE HUNDRED MILLION IN
SAVINGS FOR SCHOOLS COMMUNITY.
IF YOU DID OF UNFUNDED LIGHT
PAY DOWN YOU'D GET. A MUCH
LARGER AMOUNT OF SAVINGS OVER
TIME BUT NOT AS MUCH IN THE
NEXT COUPLE IS YOU GET UP. YOU
CAN GET A POTENTIAL. BUT TO GET
THAT SAVED OVER THE COURSE OF
THE NEXT COUPLE DECADES. GOT IT
THANK YOU VERY HELPFUL. WE'LL
FIND IT YOU CAN SEE THE WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO MAKE SOME
DECISIONS AT SOME POINT HERE
AND THAT'S WHY IT'S VERY VERY
IMPORTANT ON THE ONE TIME
SPENDING IN THE PROGRAM'S
FIGURE OUT. WHAT EXACTLY- V.
EXPERTS HOPE TO SEE
ACCOMPLISHED A ONE TIME
EXPENDITURE OF THE MONEY SO WE
CAN TRIAGE THE EXPENDITURES AND
DECIDE. TO THE EXTENT WE NEED
SIDE WHICH THE MOST IMPORTANT
AND THAT THE SHOULD BE. HAVE
COME. A CAR. PENSION LEAVE
WHETHER WE SEND IT TO AS RING
TO GET TO IN A FEW ADDITIONAL
SPUR. CASE FUNDING THAT THIS.
DARE HAVING TO DIG OF THEIR
CHEN. ANYWAY OR WHETHER WE FIND
TIME AT. PRO THE MAY OR MAY NOT.
COME THE SAME DEGREE OF.
FISSION SEE IN A DIFFERENCE AND
SHE- SO. LOOK FOR TO THE CAN
CAL. YEAH WE LOOK WITH WELL
LOOK FOR TO THOSE COVER. I
WOULD LIKE TO OUR NOTE OF CA.
IN THE PAST THE THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IN ANY MONEY PROVIDED
TO THE STATE AND FOR PER.
THIRDS HAS DONE ON A NINETY
SIDE OF BUDGET TO DO. THE
BILLION DOLLARS WITHIN THE- WE
BE NAY OF. A DIFFERENT PROPOSED.
RESEARCH BUT WELL THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT IF THEY HAVE AN
UNFUNDED LIABILITY THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO PAY IF YOU
MAKE AN ON BEHIND THE MONEY
THEY CRIED AS THEY PLAYED AT A
NINETY EIGHT SO WHETHER THEY
PAY AT A NINETY EIGHT OR-
NINETY EIGHT OR WE PUT OUT OF
SOMETHING ELSE. IT CAN COME OUT
OF ANY OF THE POTS. SEEMS TO ME.
OKAY ANYBODY ELSE- BEFORE I LET
YOU GO MISTER ELIO CAN YOU
COMMENT ON MY- I WAS READING
YOUR REPORT THIS REPORT HERE ON
PAGE TWENTY TWO AND MY
PRINCIPLE OR OTHER. SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR STATISTIC VERSUS
TEACHER WHO WON YES HELLO MY
COLLEAGUE WILK AND SAYS I DON'T
KNOW WHAT OTHER SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR ME YES FOR A
GROUP CALLED THE ONLY WAY I CAN
COME AND I THINK THAT. THAT
DATA SOURCES BETTER LIVING THE
CONVERSATION TO SOME OF ISSUE.
THERE THAT THAT THEY'VE PRETTY.
THAT'S A INDIVIDUAL WHAT AND
CREDENTIAL AND THAT CAN BE AN A
VARIETY OF- POSITIONS IN A
SCHOOL OR SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
SO I CAN INCLUDE PRINTABLE
THERE'S THE- BUT OUT OF THE- SO
WHAT COULD. SOMEONE CURRICULUM
BUT ALSO GETTING. OUR STAFF TO
MY NOT BE SOME OF THE MAY BE ON
THIS SITE FROM THE MAY BE SAY
FOR THEM AT A DISTRICT OFF
ADMIN WORK WITHIN SCHOOLS OUT
AND THE THING ON ON THE CASE SO
THERE IS A IT'S A BROAD
CHARACTER CATTLE TURNBERRY
PROBABLY RIGHT IN THE NUMBER TO
YOU LOOKS PRETTY BIG IN TERMS
OF A RATIO BECAUSE TEACHERS AND
IT. THE THIRTY. I THINK THE
WILL GO CAN LOOK AT THE DATA
THAT WE PULL THE FROM I DON'T
THINK WE'RE ABLE TO PULL
SEPARATE OUT SO MANY OF THOSE
ARE JUST PRINCIPLES VERSES
OTHER POSITION BUT WE IF WE DO
HAVE THAT ABILITY WE CAN TRY TO
SHARE THAT INFORMATION WITH
YOU. SAY IT'S ON. TWENTY TWO OF
THE YES. I WILL NOTE THAT THE-
LA- PULLS OUT IN A SEPARATE
CATEGORY. STUDENT SERVICES
STAFF SO CANCERS PSYCHOLOGISTS
SOCIAL WORKERS NURSES SPEECH
AND LANGUAGE. SPECIALIST IN
LIBRARIANS APPEAR TO BE A
DIFFERENT CATEGORY AND THAT'S
BECAUSE THEY'RE- DIFFERENT
CREDENTIALS AND SO. WHY I GUESS
WHAT I'D LIKE IT'S A LITTLE BIT
OF. A DISCO THIS. SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARING SO I'M NOT. DWELL ON
ANYMORE BUT I WOULD LIKE SOME
DATA FROM SOMEBODY AS TO WHAT.
THIS MEANS BECAUSE- TWO WILL.
PRINCE OF OTHER SCHOOL IN. TWO
ELEVEN F. T. TEACHER RATIO. IS
A BETTER RATIO THAN OUR STUDENT
TO TEACHER RATIOS SO I'D LIKE
TO MAKE SURE THAT SOMEBODY'S
TAKING A LOOK AT THAT EVEN IF
IT'S NOT ME AND THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE OKAY SO MAYBE YOU
ALL CAN GET TOGETHER AND YET
ONLY WHAT I'M WHAT I'M MISSING
OR WHICH DATA POINT I NEED TO
HELP OUR- GREAT. THIRTY ON.
YOUR GO BACK TO WORK WITH YOUR
SEVEN THE SUMMER MISSION AND I
WOULD SAY ON THIS AS WE BECAUSE
IT'S A BRA TERM IT REVERSED A
LOT OF POSITIONS THAT EITHER WE
ARE SCHOOL SITE OR A DISTRICT
CAMPUS MANY OF THEM ARE ARE.
THINGS THAT ARE- I THINK NOT
THAT'S A CONSIDERED SERVER.
ADMIN BUT DOING SOMETHING THAT
THAT THEY MIGHT BE WORKING IN
MULTIPLE SCHOOLS THEY MIGHT BE
DOING THINGS LIKE. COACHING
AUTUMN THAT ARE THAT THERE ARE
ISSUES THAT ARE BETTER NOT SORT
OF THING WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHERE TO PUT THEM WITH THAT. IN
THE CLASSROOM OR OUTSIDE OF THE
CLASSROOM- I WOULD ALSO JUST ON
THE ADMINISTRATOR ISSUES ON
MOST OF. THE TH RECOGNITION
WIDE RANKINGS ON HOW WE DO ON
THE NEWS. JUSTICE STUDENTS IS
USUALLY THE THAT'S DONE.
CALIFORNIA USE RANK VERY HIGH
IN TERMS OF WHAT THOSE WITH
THOSE NUMBERS ARE SOFT. WELL
WE'VE BEEN CRITICAL YEAH I'M
EVERY JOB IS A VALUABLE JOB AN
EDUCATION AND ANYTHING THAT
ANYBODY DOES TO CONTRIBUTE TO
EDUCATION OF THE- YOUNG AND NOT
SO YOUNG IN OUR STATE IS.
CRITICAL SO. JUST INTEREST. OR
DATA IT JUST CAUGHT MY EYE. I
WILL. TAKE ANYMORE TIME BUT WE
CAN. SEVERAL OUTSIDE THIS UP.
HAVE A COVERS A WITH THE- IN.
WHAT OF THIS. MEANS THAT. I CAN
YOU OFF THE YOU WERE GOING TO
TALK TO BUT SOMETHING ELSE
ANOTHER DOES IT. I THINK. OKAY
I'LL JUST READ CONVERSATIONS. I
KNOW THE SUPER. OKAY THIS
MORNING BUT REGARD SPECIFICALLY
THE SPECIALIZED WERE EXCITED
ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITIES. EXIST
IN THIS BUDGET FOR. BECAUSE
I'LL BE SHARING SOME A LITTLE
BIT A DATE WITH THE ON THE NEXT
PANEL TO SHOWCASE OR THE
CORRELATION BETWEEN SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE'RE FACING AT THE
STATE- OVERALL WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE DATA AND WHAT TYPES OF
SPENDING INITIATIVES ARE BEING
PUT IN PLACE PARTICULARLY I'LL
JUST MENTION SAYS TO- RESERVE
EDUCATION FOR CHILDREN STARTING
IN EARLY CHILDHOOD IN PRESCHOOL
REALLY- SETTING THAT RESETTING
THAT ON RAMP FOR HIS CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES- IS GONNA BE
CRITICAL. AND WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE SOME IDENTIFIED
BARRIER. STUDENTS WHO
DISABILITY ARE NOT SIXTY TING
CATION. AND SOME OF THOSE ARE
ALSO MENTIONED THEM IN THE
BUDGET INCLUDING- THE HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA AND FROM OTHER
AREAS. ONE OF THE- IT'S NO
SECRET TO ANYONE THAT
SPECIALIZED FUNDING CONTINUES
TO BE- SOMETHING THAT TO OUR
ATTENTION IN EVERY DISTRICT
THAT WE GO TO ESPECIALLY WITH
THE DISTRICTS THAT WE'RE
WORKING WITH AND- I WOULD SAY
BECAUSE OF- IN PART. THE
UNFUNDED MANDATE THAT WE HAVE
FROM THE FIFTH THAT'S BUT ALSO
BECAUSE- IT DOES WE DO HAVE
STUDENTS WHO ARE MORE EXPENSIVE
AND REQUIRE A HIGHER LEVEL OF
SUPPORT AND SERVICE THAN OTHER
STUDENTS. TO BE ABLE. TO FOR ME.
AT THE LEVEL OF. IF CDS WHICH
IN OUR- SOME HAS MOVED FROM A
LOW DRIVEN. A EAST BE MILD TO
MODERATE. TEACHERS AND MUCH OF
YOUR TEACHERS- S. SPEND CHANGED
TO- TEACHERS THAT SERVE
STUDENTS WITH MILD TO MODERATE
SUPPORT NEEDS AN EXTENSIVE
SUPPORT NEED I KNOW THAT. I'M
ALL NEW THAT REALLY OUT THERE
WILL BE STUDENTS RIVER RIDGE I
LOVE CARE AND SERVICE. AND SO
THAT REALLY DOES DUBBED. WELL
WITH THE COMMUNITY THIS WHOLE
IDEA OF COMMUNITY SCHOOL MODEL
BECAUSE YOU'RE GETTING THIS
GREAT FOUNDATION OF- EXPERTISE
AND CARE AT SCHOOL SITES WHICH
THEN IT WILL CONTRIBUTE TO
BETTER OUTCOMES FOR ALL
STUDENTS INCLUDING STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES WHO A LOT OF
TIMES YOU BRING IN SUPPORT.
THAT YOU WOULD NORMALLY HAVE ON
A SCHOOL CAMPUS SO I THINK
THERE'S A LOT- TO BE HOPEFUL
FOR IN THE APPS AND WE STAND
READY. TO DO THE WORK AND ALSO
A PACK SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
CONTINUE TO THE- FACT OUT IN
THE DESERT. I DO A LITTLE MORE
DATA CANNOT DO TELL ARE YOU
WELL I WILL THIS GOOD NOW WE
CAN PUT INTO THE NEXT PANEL.
ARE YOU JUST BE. THIS MIGHT BE
A BEAST TO. OUR AS OPPOSED TO.
DOING AN OVERLY FOR MY- AND
SEVERELY. I'M ONLY SUGGESTING
THAT WE LOOK AT THE WHOLE
FUNDING FORMULA IN GENERAL BUT
THAT WE HAVE ENOUGH TO SYSTEM.
AT LEAST TALK ABOUT TO SUSTAIN
A BASE THAT MORE EQUITABLE AND
THEN WE LOOK AT WHAT YOU KNOW
HOW WHAT ARE OTHER IT'S STILL.
HOW CAN WE SORT OF LOOK AT OUR-
OPTIONS. AND ALL A GRAPH.
REALLY THAT OVERLOOKED IN
POPULAR STUDENTS ABILITIES ARE
NOT JUST STUDENTS WITH THIS.
THEY'RE ALL FOSTER YOU. LEARNER
SINCE. BUT WE DON'T. MONEY THE
SPECIAL CAN I DON'T THINK MANY
DISPUTE ABOUT THE QUESTION IS
HOW THE WAY THE WAY WE
CURRENTLY ALLOCATED UNDER THAT
SIX OF TWO FORMULA. AND THE FAN
THE FUNDING ALLOCATION THAT WAS
LOCKED IN PLACE WHEN WE SET
THAT IN CONCRETE AND HOW WE
EQUALIZE THE YOU KNOW THE PER
STUDENT- DISTRIBUTION OF FUNDS.
AND THAT NOW HOW DO WE DEAL
WITH THE FACT THAT THE
INCREASING NUMBERS OF
MODERATELY TO SEVERELY DISABLED
THIS. ACROSS IN A SETTING WHERE
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS DON'T GET
ENOUGH MONEY TO BEGIN WITH THE
EDUCATE THOSE WITH DISABILITIES
SO IT'S GONNA BE VERY INSTANT
CARS ISSUE MAY WE CAN STARTED
AT THE NEXT PANEL BUT I THINK
WE'LL HAVE TO SCHEDULE LONGER
HEARINGS ONLY IF WE STOP. MAYBE
SIX OF TO WHICH MAYBE WE DO
THANK. ELSE PERFECT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. RUN SPECIALIST RIGHT
ISSUE THREE. TO SIX PAYROLL.
THIS ISSUE NUMBER TWO AND SIXTY
ONE HUNDRED DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION SPECIAL EDUCATION
FUNDING PROPOSALS AND WE HAVE A-
MOSTLY NEW PANEL IN FRONT OF
US. SO WE'LL DO THE SAME
ROUTINE VELASCO ASK YOU TO
IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR THE
RECORD MA'AM ME ASK YOU AGAIN
STARTING TO MY LEFT TO RIGHT.
HELLO KRISTEN WHEN YOU
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION OF THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION DIVISION
THANK YOU FOR NOT RUNNING AWAY
YES MA'AM HI GOOD MORNING
MICHELLE BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SHOW. WITH MY WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. EMILY
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE THANK YOU ALL FOR
JOINING US. AND YOUR HERE'S
WHAT. ROTH ELICITED OFF OF
THANK YOU OKAY WHO WANTS TO
START VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC.
THANK YOU MA'AM MAKE GOOD
MORNING TURN MEMBERS LIST MY
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BEFORE I
GET STARTED I WANTED TO GIVE A
LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND TO OUR
OFFICE SO BETWEEN NINETEEN BUT
ACT LAID OUT A CHARGE FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION THE LEGISLATURE
AND ON STAKEHOLDERS TO
COMPREHENSIVELY EXAMINE.
SPECIAL EDUCATION WITH THE
FOCUS ON IMPROVING STUDENT
OUTCOMES SO- AS PART OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE SPOKE AND MATT WITH
AND MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS
HELPERS AND COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION AND THROUGHOUT THE
STATE TO GET A BETTER IDEA OF
WHAT IS WORKING WELL IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND WHAT NECESSARY IS
ARE NEEDED. IN ORDER TO BETTER
SUPPORT ALL OF OUR STUDENTS.
AND FOR THIS CONVERSATION CAME
SEVERAL THE PROPOSAL THAT
YOU'LL HEAR ABOUT TODAY. AND I
WANTED TO EMPHASIZE THAT THIS
IS ONLY THE BEGINNING OF A
MULTI YEAR MULTI FAITH EFFORT
OF SPECIAL EDUCATION REFORM.
AND OF COURSE THOUGHTFUL
COLLABORATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND STAKEHOLDERS
IS. REQUIRED FOR US TO ACHIEVE
OUR SHARED GOALS OF- SUPPORTING
INCLUSIVE PRACTICES AND
ENSURING EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
RESOURCES FOR ALL STUDENTS. AND
SO WITH ALL OF THAT THIS YEAR
THE GOVERNOR. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES AN OVERHAUL OF
THE SPECIAL- EDUCATION BASE
FUNDING FORMULA. SO IN THE
HANDOUT THAT THE SERGEANT.
BROUGHT AROUND. AND YOU'LL SEE
THE KEY DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE
CURRENT FUNDING FORMULA WHICH
IS EIGHTY SIX IT TOO AND THE
PROPOSED BASE FORMULA. SO IN
ORDER TO INCREASE TRANSPARENCY
FUNDING WOULD BE CALCULATED OUT
THE LA LEVEL AND SAID OF THE
SUPPLE LEVEL ALTHOUGH TOTAL
FUNDING WILL STILL BE ALLOCATED
TO THE SOUTH AS FOR
DISTRIBUTION ON THE STATUS QUO
UNFUNDED EIGHTY A WOULD BE
CALCULATED AS A THREE YEAR
ROLLING AVERAGE- AND- IT IS
BECAUSE PRIOR YEAR AND PRIOR
PRIOR YEAR EIGHTY A. M.
SUPPOSED TO KERN EIGHTY SIX.
WHICH AND THE GROUP OF THE
CURRENT YEAR PRIOR YEAR OR
PRIOR PRIOR YEAR EIGHTY A AT
THE SILVA. I AM AND ASK FOR THE
BASE THREE MOST LEDS WILL SEE A
BOOST IN THEIR BASE RATE- ELLIE
IS CURRENTLY BELOW SIX HUNDRED
AND SIXTY PER STUDENT WILL
RECEIVE A RATE OF SIX SIXTY AND
THE ONLY A STOCK ARE ABOVE.
THAT SIT SEE NUMBER WELCOME TO
GET THEIR NINETEEN TWENTY AB
SIXTY TWO RATE ADJUSTED FOR
COST OF LIVING. AS FOR THE ON
ON ALL AB SIXTY TWO OUT ON THE
FROZEN AS A ARE FOR TWO YEARS-
IF. THEY RECEIVE CALL UNDER AB
SIXTY TWO THEY WILL CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE THOUGHT. IN MY
COLLEAGUE HAS MORE INFORMATION
ON THE OTHER PROPOSALS BUT I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
ALL OF THE QUESTION ALL OF THE
QUESTION ON THE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION. WHEN WE GET TO
THAT OKAY MISS MY THAT'S NOT
YOU RIGHT. HELLO THERE YEAH
OKAY. YEAH I CAN HELP OUT WITH
THAT SO AGAIN THE SHOVEL
DEVELOPMENT OF FINANCE I'M
GONNA GO OVER SOME OF THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION PROPOSALS AND
THE GOVERNOR DESK AND AS MY
WEEK MAN. I'M I JUST IT IS THE
MULTI MULTI FOR PROCESS ON THIS
FIRST PHASE IS THE FOCUS ON
INCREASE SPECIAL EDUCATION
FUNDING INCLUDING FUNDING TO
SUPPORT PRESCHOOL AGE CHILDREN.
AND IT'S ALSO FOCUSED ON MAKING
INVESTMENTS TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT IS
UNNECESSARY AND COMING TO US.
ZERO WE CAN. WHEN THERE'S- IN
ADDITION. HUNDRED MILLION
ONGOING NINETY EIGHT FOR A-
EARLY IN OF SERVICE. FOR
PRESCHOOL AGE CHILDREN. I'M
FINE WOULD BE A- ON A ONE BASIS
TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO FUNDING
LAST YEAR- SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT ARE SERVING PRESCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN WITH THIS. PLEASE I'M
HOWEVER THIS IS THE FUNDING IS
A LITTLE DIFFERENT AND THAT IT
WOULD BE RESTRICTED TO
INCREASED OR IMPROVED SERVICES
STUDENT DISABILITIES OR IT
COULD ALSO BE USED FOR EARLY
INTERVENTION SERVICES FIRST. P.
AND I JUST WANT TO MENTION THAT
WE HAVE HEARD CONCERNS ABOUT
THIS ARE REALLY TO THIS FUNDING
IS. AROUND ISSUES OF IMPACT- A
DISTRICTS MAINTENANCE OF
EFFORT- AMMO E. AND WE ARE VERY
SENSITIVE TO THOSE CONCERNS AND
WE'RE DEFINITELY TAKING THAT
INTO CONSIDERATION. I'M HOWEVER
WE WOULD LIKETO US THAT WE
DON'T THINK IT WOULD
NECESSARILY IMPACT AND EMILY IF
IT IS WAS FOR- AN EARLY
INTERVENTION SUPPORTS. AND
PROVIDING PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT WORKING ON MTS HAS-
THINGS THAT ARE NOT NECESSARILY
IN AN IP BUT THEY COULD STILL
HELP YOUNG STRUGGLING LEARNERS-
BUT AGAIN. LISTENING TO THOSE
CONCERNS. ADDITIONALLY THE
BUDGET PROPOSES FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ONE TIME PROP NINETY
EIGHT- FOR A STUDY OF THE
CURRENT SPECIAL EDUCATION
GOVERNANCE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
SYSTEM. ON THE ADMINISTRATION'S
VISION IS FOR THE STUDY TO
EXAMINE DELIVERY SYSTEMS
ACCOUNTABILITY AND HAD A
SUPPORT ELEAZAR TO ENSURE
STUDENTS HAVE EQUITABLE ACCESS
TO RESOURCES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE- HOWEVER WE DO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
ALL. I'M FINALLY FINDING THE
SCOPE OF THE STUDY. FINALLY THE
BUDGET PROPOSALS- SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND ONE TIME FOR TWO WORK
GROUPS THAT. WHERE AND BEFORE
WE WORK GROUP WILL EXAMINE AND
PROPOSED ALTERNATE PATHWAYS TO
A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA FOR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES- AS
WE HEARD ON OUR SITE IT'S AS
THE SUMMER AND I THINK AS-
KRISTIN RIVAL A SPEAK ABOUT.
INTO MANY STUDENTS ARE PLACED
ON THE TICKET TO COMPLETION
TRACK WHICH MAY OR MAY NOT BE
APPROPRIATE- AND CREATES
BARRIERS SECONDARY PLANS FOR.
THE DISABILITY SINCE SUPPORT
GROUP IS REALLY LOOKING AT
ENSURING THAT ALL STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES HAVE EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO GRADUATE WITH A HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA. AND THEN THE
FINALLY OTHER BULLOCKS. FINING
FIFTH Y. DANDER. TEMPLATE I CAN
GET BOGGED BY COMPLY MAN AND
THERE'S AN- IN EXAMINING HOW
PIECE COULD BE BETTER DEFINED
TO IMPROVE OUR STRENGTH. SOME
STUDENTS. OF COURSE. PERCENT OF
THE- NEVER. THIS IS A FREE BILL
LOCAL REPRESENTATIVE FROM AT
LEAST OF COURSE AND OF COURSE
THE STAFF OTHER RATHER STAKE I
KNOW THAT WAS A LOT I KNOW
THERE'S SOME ON BUT YEAH
MICHAEL YEAH TO TAKE QUESTIONS
FLORA A QUESTION ON THAT BEFORE
MARK THE ONLY. IF IN THIS
QUESTION ON THE TO A FIFTH
MILLION DOLLARS IN A WHISPER A
LITTLE BIT ON THIS LAST YEAR IN
THIS BY OF. THE FOR TO FIVE
YEAR OLDS AND HOW WE INCREASE
FUNDING- IN SPECIAL AND YOU
KNOW EVERY DOLLAR OF INCREASES
OF IS A BENEFIT. JUST ABOUT IT
I'M SURE EVERY DISTRICT I WAS
GONNA SAY JUST ABOUT EVERY
DISTRICT BUT EVERY DISTRICT. SO
WITH THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS HOW DO YOU I
REALIZE IT'S ALSO SAYS IMPROVE
BUT YOU IN ZURICH OR PROVE
SERVICES. IF YOU DON'T. AT
PERSONNEL. AND IF YOU ED
PERSONNEL HOW DO YOU IN
PERSONNEL IF THE MONEY'S ONE
TIME SO THAT'S SORT OF A TWO
PART QUESTION AND THEN I'LL
GIVE YOU THE THIRD QUESTION IN
ADVANCE WHICH IS WHETHER WE
TAKE THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS RECOGNIZE THAT
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT AREA THREE
TO FIVE YEAR OLDS EARLY
INTERVENTION. I BELIEVE THE LA-
IS SUGGESTED BUT- REGARDLESS
WHY DON'T WE TAKE THAT AND JUST
CALL IT ON TIME. ONGOING RATHER
ONGOING FUNDING AND ALLOW THE
DISTRICTS TO SET UP AN RELY ON
A CERTAIN FUNDING STREAM. TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO THREE TO
FIVE YEAR OLDS THAT. NO TO DATE
THEY'VE HAD DIFFICULTY DOING.
THOSE ARE THE THREE QUESTIONS
PROJECTS THE TOTALS ONLY AS ONE
OF TIME BUT IN MOSCOW YOU GET
THREE OKAY HOPEFULLY I CAN
ANSWER THREE OF THEM ARE MEMBER
TO ANSWER YOUR FIRST QUESTION
ABOUT- HOW DO WE YOU KNOW
PROVIDE INCREASED IMPROVE
SERVICES. WITHOUT ADDING PERSON
NOW- I THINK THAT IN OUR SIDE
THIS IS A SUMMER AND WE HEARD
FROM A LOT OF FOLKS WHO ARE YOU
KNOW TRYING TO PROVIDE SERVICES
TO THE PRE SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN-
BUT THEY'RE COMING TO A LOT OF
BARRIERS WITH. EVEN FINDING
PERSONAL ALMOND SO THEY'RE
HAVING TO CONTRACT FOR SERVICES
AND SO I THINK THAT THAT IS A
GREAT EXAMPLE OF- CONTRACTING
FOR SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGIST
FOR EXAMPLE AS WE KNOW THERE'S
A SHORTAGE. A SHORTAGE THOSE.
OF YOU SO THE ALTERNATIVE IS TO
HIRE SOMEBODY SO WE GIVE THE
MONEY WE ALLOWED THEM TO HER.
SO MAYBE THEY BUMP THE CUT THE
WAGE AND BENEFIT PACKAGE UP FOR
WHATEVER YOU CAN DO AND THE
EDUCATE ENVIRONMENT. SO PUTTING
ON A PER. IT'S ONE TIME MONEY
AND DOESN'T THAT MEAN IF THE
MONEY ISN'T THERE NEXT YEAR
THAT WE THEN DO WHAT WE LEYVA
PERSON OFF FOR WE SHIP FROM
SOMEPLACE ELSE OR WE CANCEL THE
PROGRAM I MEAN I'M JUST TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND THE- THE LOGIC
HERE. BECAUSE THE USE OF THE
PHRASE INCREASED OR IMPROVED
SERVICES IS NOT MY PHRASE
THAT'S THE PHRASE THE
ADMINISTRATION USED IN PUTTING
FORTH THE BUDGET PROPOSAL AND
THAT TO ME MEANS YOU'VE ADDED
SOMETHING AND YOU'VE ADDED
SOMETHING WAS ONE TIME MONEY
WHICH DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE AM
I MAKING IN MY MAKING SENSE YES
I THINK SO OF IT WHERE YOU CAN
SAY NO. I I'M UP. YOU KNOW I'M
A ONE YEAR IN A ROOM FULL OF
EXPERTS OF NOT EVERYTHING I SAY
MAKES SENSE GO AHEAD. OF ME
YEAH I KNOW AND I THINK THAT
THAT IS A GREAT- POINT AND WILL
DEFINITELY TAKE THOSE CONCERNS
INTO CONSIDERATION- AGAIN THE
FUNDING CAN ALSO BE USED AS FOR
EARLY INTERVENTION SERVICES
MORE BROADLY ON TO EXPAND AND
TSS RIGHT TO. THIS KIND OF
BUILD MORE SUPPORT BY THE
CONTRACTING WHETHER DOING
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT WHICH
TENDS TO BE ONE TIME- COULD
REALLY HELP THOSE YOUNG
LEARNERS. BUT BUT WE DEFINITELY
YOU. DELIVERY OF QUOTE. IDEA
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE BUT
MY QUESTION IS ABOUT THE SELF
US US I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S BOTH
OF YOU OR THE FIRST- LADY THAT
PRESENTED. I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHY ONE OF MY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS DISLIKE SELFLESS SO
MUCH THAT THEY FEEL THAT THEY
FEEL THAT THE SELF WAS. FOR
ONLY THERE TO DENY SERVICES. TO
THE STUDENTS AND THE WIND UP IN
A LOT OF LAWSUITS AT- THIS
PARTICULAR DISTRICT AND I THINK
OTHER DISTRICTS TO I THINK THIS
DISTRICT JUST HAPPENS TO BE. A
BIT MORE. ALL SO DO YOU THINK
THAT. CHANGING THIS FORMULA
FROM THE A. B. SIX SO TWO
FORMULA THE EIGHTY A
CALCULATION WHICH CURRENTLY IS
AT THE SUPPLE LEVEL. CALCULATED
AT THE LA A LEVEL. WITH THAT
DAY IN DO YOU HEAR OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE NOT HAPPY WITH SELF AS-
SORRY IT'S KIND OF A CONVOLUTED
QUESTION. THREE AND SO WHY
CAN'T NECESSARILY SPEAK
DIRECTLY TO THAT PARTICULAR
ELEMENT IN THERE HELP US- WE'VE
HEARD JUST MAKES THINGS AND I
THINK THAT. SO THE REASON WHY
WE WANTED TO DO THESE
CALCULATIONS AT THE LA LEVEL IS
BECAUSE TRANSPARENCY HAS BEEN-
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE HEARD AS A
CONCERN OF AND THE AS THE SB
SIX MODEL STANDS IT DOESN'T
REALLY REFLECT THE GROWTH OR
DECLINE- OF INDIVIDUAL ELEAZAR
REALLY JUST TAKES THE SALT INTO
ACCOUNT. AN AN **** OR YOU KNOW
THE ROLE OF AN REALIZE SERVICES
AND THAT RELATIONSHIP IT VARIES
SO MUCH ACROSS THE STATE WHICH
IS AGAIN AS MY COLLEAGUE WITH
PAYING WHY WE ARE. THIS
GOVERNMENT SO THAT WE EXAMINE
THIS BECAUSE OF THIS AND IS A
OF A BLACK THAT WE ARE NOT
QUITE SURE OF. THAT IS FAIR SO
YOU'RE BEING THAT CALCULATING
THE EIGHTY A CALCULATION OF THE
VALLEY A LEVEL WILL GIVE US
BETTER TRANSPARENCY THAN DOING
IT NOW WITH THE SELF LEVEL. YES
OKAY WELL TRANSPARENT IS ALWAYS
THANKS THANK YOU. THERE'S
ANOTHER STEP BECOMING OUT ISN'T
THERE IS PRIVATE STUDY GOING ON.
AND SO THERE IS A- STUDY THAT
WAS PRIVATELY COMMISSIONED AND-
THAT IS BEING CONDUCTED BY WEST
ED AND THAT IS REALLY LOOKING
AT THE FINANCING OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND- SO FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND A COMPREHENSIVE LOOK
I AM THE FINANCING OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION CALIFORNIA. HASN'T
REALLY BEEN DONE IN OVER TWENTY
YEARS SO I BELIEVE THAT
THEY'RE- JUST TRYING TO SEE HOW
THINGS ARE AND GET SOME CLARITY
ON THE STRUCTURE OF HOW THINGS
STAND AT THIS CURRENT JUNCTURE
NOW WITH JUST WITH RESPECT TO
THE STUDY THAT'S CURRENTLY
BEING PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET IN
THE APPROPRIATIONS DO WE HAVE
SOME. CLEAR QUESTIONS THAT
WE'RE ASKING- BE ADDRESSED IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE STUDY SELF
OF WAS MENTIONED. SO I C<c.cyan> I</c>
CAN TAKE BACK SO AGAIN
ADMINISTRATION VISION IS FOR TO
LOOK AT GOVERNANCE
ACCOUNTABILITY- YOU KNOW SINCE
THE CREATION OF SELFIES THERE
HAVE BEEN A LOT OF CHANGES AND
EDUCATION GENERALLY WITH THE
CREATION OF. ON THE AL CAPP
RIGHT THE DASHBOARD- ANDSO
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSED BE LOOK AT IN THE
STUDY AGAIN WE ARE VERY OPEN TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND YOUR
STAFF. QUESTIONS THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SEE ANSWERED AROUND
GOVERNANCE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
IN SPECIAL EDUCATION. WELL I
ASSUME WOULD NOT. WITHOUT
SPECIFICALLY KNOWING. THAT PART
OF THE- RATIONALE FOR THE SELF
OF CREATION AND THE WAY BACK
WAS TO CENTRALIZE RESOURCES AND
PROVIDE SOME CENTRALIZATION OF
SKILLS AND RESOURCES THAT A
PARTICULAR DISTRICT MIGHT NOT
BE ABLE TO AFFORD TO MAINTAIN-
ON AN ON CALL ARE AS NEEDED
BASIS IS THAT. CORRECT YEAH
DEFINITELY SO THEY WERE CREATED
TO CREATE ECONOMIES OF SCALE
RIGHT- IN PER CAPITA I SUPPORT-
SINCE YOU KNOW SINCE THEN THERE
HAVE BEEN A LOT OF- THE
CREATION OF SINGLE DISTRICTS
HELP US- AND SO THEY'RE JUST
BEEN A LOT OF CHANGES AROUND
THAT ENDS THAT NEED TO BE
FURTHER LOOKED AT AND STUDIED.
RIGHT I SUPPOSE ECONOMIES SCALE
ONE THING THAT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY MEAN THAT MONEY
STILL HAS TO FLOW. IN THAT
DIRECT WHICH I ASSUME IS ONE OF
THE ISSUES WILL BE ADDRESSED IN
THIS STUDY THAT YOU ARE GOING
COMMISSION. CORRECT YEAH
LOOKING AT THE FUNDING AND HOW
IT INTERACTS WITH EVIDENCE.
THAT THE OTHER QUESTIONS
EARLIER. WHO'S NEXT. GOOD
MORNING SENATOR IS AMY LEE WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE THE SERGEANTS SHOULD
HAVE DISTRIBUTED A HANDOUT FROM
CHILD SPEAKING WITH ON TODAY SO
TURNING TO PAGE ONE JUST
BRIEFLY BY WAY OF BACKGROUND
AND ELEVEN POINT 7% OF K.
TWELVE STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
RECEIVE SPECIAL EDUCATION
SERVICES AND THIS YEAR HAS BEEN
STEADILY INCREASING FOR THE
PAST DECADE ALONG WITH THE
INCREASE IN IDENTIFICATION
RATES HAVE. INCREASED IS IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION COSTS I'M SO
AS YOU CAN SEE ON THE FIGURE ON
PAGE ON. SO STATE AND FEDERAL
FUNDING LEVELS HAVE MAINLY ROOM
REMAINS THE SAME AS A RESULT
LOCAL GENERAL PURPOSE FUNDING
MOSTLY THERE I'LL SEE IF I HAVE
HAVE BEEN COVERING A GROWING
SHARE OF THIS COST SUCH THAT
LOCAL FUNDING COVERS ABOUT 60%
OF COST COMPARED 250% A DECADE
AGO. TWO TWO FACTORS CONTRIBUTE
TO THESE GROWING COST. FIRST
THE SHARE OF STUDENTS WITH
RELATIVELY SEVERE DISABILITIES
HAS ALMOST DOUBLED SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND NOW CONSISTS OF 3%
OF OVERALL STUDENT ENROLLMENT.
THESE DISABILITIES TYPICALLY
ARE MORE IN REQUIRE MORE
INTENSIVE AND EXPENSIVE
SERVICES. AND THE MOST NOTABLE
RISES IN AUTISM WHICH AFFECTED
ONE IN SIX HUNDRED STUDENTS AT
THE TO TECH TWO DECADES AGO.
COMPARED TO ONE IN FIFTY
STUDENTS TODAY SO THAT'S ALMOST
TWELVE FOLD INCREASE. ANOTHER
CONTRIBUTING FACTOR IS A RISE
IN TEACHER SALARY AND PENSION
COSTS ARE WHICH ARE ALL
AFFECTING GENERAL EDUCATION AS
WELL. MOVING ON TO EACH. OTHER
PHIL AT AT CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT
SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING MODEL
OBVIOUSLY PROVIDES FUNDING
BASED ON OVERALL STUDENT
ATTENDANCE- AND STUDENT TENDONS
IS USED RATHER THAN A MORE
DIRECT MEASURE OF COST. IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT STUDENT
THAT IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT
SCHOOLS HAVE LITTLE INCENTIVE
TO OVER IDENTIFY STUDENTS OR
SERVE STREETS AND UNNECESSARILY
EXPENSIVE WAYS WE THINK THIS
BREAKS THE FACT THAT HIGH
BETWEEN. BEING AN
IDENTIFICATION FOR STUDENTS.
COVERED THE- ENDING AT THE PER
STUDENT FUNDING RATES UNDER AB
SIXTY TWO HAVE LARGELY VARIED
BECAUSE OF HISTORICAL REASONS-
AS FINANCE HAS ALREADY
MENTIONED IN THAT NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET AND THERE WAS A
DIRECTIVE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
MAKE STATUTORY CHANGES TO. THAT
WERE DESIGNED OF ACADEMIC
OUTCOMES FOR STUDENTS- AS- A
REAL RESPONSIVE TO THAT DATE
MINISTRATION ENDED UP
IDENTIFYING SEVERAL CHALLENGES-
IN SPECIAL EDUCATION AND
RELATED TO GROWING. STATE
MENTAL HEALTH AND SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL NEEDS FEATURES THAT
ARE NOT PREPARED FOR INCLUDES A
PACK PRACTICES STORAGE IS OF
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHERS AND
SPECIALISTS AND- BACK OF
CLEARING THE SCENE GEN FROM THE
C. TO PROMOTE. THE PRACTICES.
THIRTY ADDRESS THESE IT THE
GOVERNOR. TO MAKE REFORMS IN.
CATION FINANCE AND OTHER. I A
MORE FEES. AND NEXT PAGE WE
BREAK OUTS THE- SPECIAL
EDUCATION PROPOSALS INTO THREE
GROUPINGS. SO ON THIS TABLE
HERE- WILL START COVERING I
WILL START WITH THE PROPOSED
BASED FUNDING CHANGES AND THIS
INCLUDES TWO PROPOSALS WHICH
FINANCES ALREADY EXPLAINED- IN
TERMS OF THEM. THE LAST PAGE
THAT'S OKAY I'M JUST SLOW
APPROACH. AND THIS IS THE YEAH
THIS IS JUST A MEATY PART I
THINK WE'RE COUNTY RIGHT NOW-
SO IN TERMS OF THAT BASE
FUNDING INCREASES THIS WOULD
RISE GREAT RAISE RATES FOR A
MOST SELF AS TO SIX HUNDRED AND
SIXTY DOLLARS PER STUDENT WE%
FIND THIS PROPOSAL TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH THE ORIGINAL
INTENT OF EIGHTY SIX OH TWO BY
ELIMINATING. RATHER ARBITRARY
DIFFERENCES IN BASE RATES AND
WE RECOMMEND LEGISLATURE ADOPT
THE PROPOSED I'M GOING BASS
AUGMENTATION. SECOND THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES A THREE YEAR
ROLLING AVERAGE AND STUDENT
ATTENDANCE WE RECOMMEND ALSO
ADOPTING THIS PROPOSAL AS IT
WOULD SMOOTH THE FUNDING FOR
DISTRICTS WITH DECLINING
ENROLLMENT WHICH IS THE CASE
FOR MOST DISTRICTS IN THE STATE
WE DO HAVE A NOTE THAT GROWING
DISTRICTS MEETS THE SMALLER
ANNUAL INCREASES RELATIVE TO
THEIR ENROLLMENT GROWTH. AS FAR
AS FINANCING REFORM GOES MORE
GENERALLY WE'RE NOT ENTIRELY
SURE HOW THE CHALLENGES THAT
MINISTRATION CITED REALLY.
RELATE BACK TO THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING MODEL ITSELF
WE BELIEVE THAT EIGHTY SIX OF
TO PROVIDE SCHOOLS WITH THE
NECESSARY FRY FLEXIBILITY TO.
FIND FUNDING IN WAYS THAT ALIGN
WITH STUDENT NEEDS AND THAT
INCLUDES THINGS LIKE PROMOTE
INCLUSIVE PRACTICES. AND
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL STUDENT
SERVICES. AND WE THINK THAT
MENSURATION HAS YET TO
RIDICULOUS HOW THE CURRENT
FUNNY MONEY MODEL CONTRIBUTES
TO THE PROBLEM CITED. MAKING
IDENTIFYING WE ARE THOSE ISSUES
ARE ACTUALLY REALLY HELPFUL IN
TERMS OF GUIDING QUITE FUTURE
FUNDING REFORM LOOKS LIKE.
MOVING ON TO THAT SECOND ROLE
IN THE TABLE. WE DISCUSS THAT
STUDIES IN THE WORK GROUPS ARE
ALSO IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL. AND SO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL PROVIDES FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ONE TIME FOR STUDY AND
SPECIAL EDUCATION GOVERNANCE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY AS WELL AS A
COMBINED SIX HUNDRED MEN
THOUSAND ONE TIME TO CONVENE TO
BURKE GROUPS. HERE WE ARE
ENCOURAGED LEGISLATURE TO VIEW
THESE PROPOSALS AS
OPPORTUNITIES TO WEIGH AND
INFORM FUTURE PHASES OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION REFORM. THE TO THE
EXTENT THAT THESE PRIOR THESE
AREAS ALIGNED WITH LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES THAT'S FAIR BUT TO
THE EXTENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS OTHER PRIORITIES IN MAY
CONSIDER WHETHER OR NOT STUDIES
OR WORKGROUPS WOULD BE HELPFUL
IN PURSUING THOSE OTHER
PRIORITIES. SO FOR INSTANCE
MANY DISTRICTS ARE SEEN
INCREASES AND THEIR LOCAL
EDUCATION COSTS AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER. THE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONSIDER FUNNY STUDY THAT WOULD
HELP I CAN'T AFFORD THE COST
PROVIDE SOME. IF UNDER THE
CURRENT ABC TOMORROW. COULD YOU
PLEASE JUST LATER COULD DIRECT
I OTHER I PRIORITY MORE
DIRECTLY SUCH AS- THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER X.
EGGS. IN TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO DISTRICTS
IMPLEMENTING INCLUSIVE
PRACTICES. LASTLY THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES BED TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME FOR
PRESCHOOL AS DESCRIBED IN THAT
LAST ROOM THE TABLE. THIS
FUNDING WOULD BE ALLOCATED IN
THE SAME- AS THAT NINETEEN
TWENTY PRESCHOOL FINING WISE BY
HEAD COUNT OF SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES AND
ADISTRICT. ON AND AS FINANCES
MENTIONED IN CONTRAST TO THE
NINETEEN TWENTY. FUNDING THIS
FUNDING IS INTENDED TO INCREASE
OUR IMPROVE PROGRAM SERVICE
SAYS. AND SO ARE OUR CONCERNS
VERY MUCH A ONE TWO YEARS
SENATOR ROSS WE'RE NOT ENTIRELY
SURE WHAT THE INTENTION IS WITH
ONE TIME FINDING. TO IT AT
IMPROVE IMPROVE OR INCREASE
PROGRAM SERVICES AND WE THINK
EXPECTING DISTRICTS TO DO SUCH
FRIENDS ARE RATHER CONFUSING
MESSAGES MESSAGE. DISTRICTS
WOULD BE ABLE TO HIRE
ADDITIONAL STAFF TO PROVIDE
MORE SERVICES WITH ONE TIME
FUNDING NOR THE LIKELY TO
INCREASE SPENDING ON SPECIAL
EDUCATION. SERVICES AS- INTO
THE SLOT FUNDING AND FUTURE
UNDER FEDERAL LAW. THE WE READ.
THE LEGISLATURE SAD YOU THAT TO
PROPOSE TWO HUNDRED OF MILLION
INTO AN ON GOING BASIS
AUGMENTATION AND SETTING USE
THIS TO FIND INCLUDE A PRE
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN INTO THE
BASE FORMULA. THE STATE DOES
NOT CURRENTLY PROVIDE ONGOING
FUNDING FOR DISTRICTS TO
SERVICE AGE GROUP DESPITE
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS THAT
DISTRICTS STARTS TO PROVIDING
SPECIAL EDUCATION SERVICES
STARTING AND CAL TO THIRD
BIRTHDAY. WE BELIEVE THAT
EXPANDING THE BASE FORMULA TO
INCLUDE PRE SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN
WOULD ALLOW THE STATE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE LOCAL
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH SERVING
THIS AGE GROUP. WE ALSO WE
WOULD RECOMMEND MODIFYING THE
BASE FORMULATO DOUBLE COUNT
FOR KINDERGARTEN ATTENDANCE AS
AN APPROPRIATE AND
STRAIGHTFORWARD METRIC THE
PROXY FOR PRE SCHOOL
ATTENDANCE. AND THAT CONCLUDES
OUR COMMENTS BUT I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
SO WE HAVE FROM IF WE WERE
INTERESTED IN SWIMMING. WE WERE
ABLE TO REALLOCATE MONEY TO DO
THIS. IF WE WERE INTERESTED IN
TRYING TO ADDRESS THE- INCREASE
IN THE INCIDENCE OF MORE
SEVERELY DISABLED STUDENTS IN
THE MODERATE. TO SEVERELY
DISABLED CATEGORY. AND THE COST
INCREASED COST OF EDUCATING
THOSE STUDENTS TO BE ANY
IMPEDIMENT TO. US FOLLOWING
ADDITIONAL MONEY OUT TO THROUGH
THE SELFLESS TO THE DISTRICTS
FOR THAT PURPOSE ON TOP OF THE
BASE RATE. I THINK IT WOULD
JUST BE A FIX OUT AWAY TO MOST
APPROPRIATE ALLOCATE THAT MNEY
I THINK THERE ARE VARIOUS
CONSIDERATIONS IN TERMS OF HOW
THE LEGISLATURE COULD DO THAT-
BUT I THINK THERE ARE SOME MAIN
GUIDING PRINCIPLES THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD PROBABLY
HAVE IN MIND. FIRST IS HOW
CHANGES TO AB SIX OH TWO YOU
WOULD CHANGE INCENTIVES OVER
IDENTIFIER POTENTIALLY OVER
SERVE STUDENTS- IF WE DO FLOW
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. TO
DISTRICTS AND FELL BUT AS THE
QUESTION IS WHETHER OR NOT THIS
CHANGES BEHAVIOR IN A WAY THAT
WE DIDN'T NECESSARILY INTEND TO
AS A STATE. ONLY HAS A
QUESTION- I'M UP I UNDERSTAND I
THINK I UNDERSTAND THAT CONCEPT
I'M NOT SURE I UNDERSTAND. THE
CONCEPT IN THE IMPACT OF THE
CONCEPT IN THE CURRENT
SITUATION WHERE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE SPENDING AN EXTRA.
IS IT 40% OR SIXTY PERCENT. OF
THE GENERAL FUND TO FUND
SPECIAL EDUCATION ANYWAY SO.
OUR OUR AREN'T THEY GOING TO
HAVE TO SPEND THE MONEY ANYWAY
AND- CAN I MAKING SENSE SO I
JUST GIVE THEM AN EXTRA. FIFTY
DOLLARS A ON IF IT'S DONE ON AN
EIGHTY A BASIS OR A STUN ON AN
EIGHTY A BASIS EIGHTY EIGHT. IN
TERMS OF MODERATE TO SEVERELY
DISABLED STUDENT IF WE CAN
FIGURE THAT OUT SO IS MY
QUESTION MAKE SENSE HOW DOES IT
REALLY MAKES HOW DOES THAT.
CONCERN MANIFEST ITSELF IN THE
ENVIRONMENT WE CURRENTLY HAVE
WHERE IT'S NOT A 100% FUNDED
ANYWAY. SURE CITING THE
QUESTION THEN IS HOW YOU OUT
HOW YOU ALLOCATE THAT MONEY
RIGHT SO FOR INSTANCE IF YOU
HAVE. MORE MONEY THAT IS GOING
TO BE PROVIDED FOR A STUDENT
WITH FOR INSTANCE AUTISM. AND
YOU MADE IT IT MIGHT YOU MIGHT
AND SEE ADDITIONAL MONEY COMING
FROM THE STATE IF YOU HAVE
EIGHT CHILD'S THAT IS
CLASSIFIED IT WITH AN AUTISM.
ON DISABILITY THE QUESTION THEN
BECOMES WALL FROM A FISCAL
PERSPECTIVE DEAL YOU THINK THAT
THERE MIGHT BE ADDITIONAL A
DIAGNOSTIC DIE DIAGNOSES AND
IDENTIFICATION OF THESE RATE.
HAS THIS BUT THEN COME WITH
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. SO I THINK
IT IS THAT A BAD THING SO I
THINK THAT IS A REALLY GOOD
QUESTION TO ASK- BUT I WOULD
SAY FIRST THAT IN TERMS OF THE
RESEARCH THERE HAVE BEEN VERY
STUDIES LOOKING AT STATES AND
HOW WHEN THEY TRANSITION OVER
TO. A MODEL THAT IS WHAT WE
CALL CONSENSUS SPACE WHICH IS
WHAT AB SIXTY TWO IS IT DOESN'T
TIED NECESSARILY TO A DIRECT
MEASURE OF COSTA JUST OVERALL
STUDENT COUNTY HAVE. OVERLY
OVERLAY I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT
YES EXACTLY HEARINGS THE
DISMANTLING ABC TO EXACTLY- I
AND ENERGY STANDING THERE AND-
BUT AND- SORRY WE DO SEE IT
FROM OTHER STATES THAT.
CHANGING THE FUNDING MECHANISM
DOES CHANGE BEHAVIOR I THINK IS
A QUITE A I WANT TO MENTION-
DISPERSED BUT SECOND AND- IT'S-
I BECAUSE THIS IS MORE OF AN
ART THAN A SCIENCE YES IT
DEFINITELY AS YOU SAY JOHN HAS
IS ARTISTIC AND AT A CERTAIN
LEVEL YEAH I HAVE TO TAKE WHAT
YOU SAY IS GOSPEL BECAUSE IT'S
ART AND SCIENCE AND WHO KNOWS
WHAT WE'RE MORE JOHN IS ON THE
SCALE AND YES EXACTLY AND SO WE
I THINK WE ARE JUST VERY
COGNIZANT THAT THOSE MIGHT BE
MORE PRESENT IN THE ROOM WHEN
THOSE CLASSIFICATIONS ARE BEING
MADE THEN THEY OUGHT TO BE
BECAUSE THERE IS ADDITIONAL
MONEY TIED TO A CERTAIN
CLASSIFICATION. AND THAT IS OUR
MAJOR CONCERN WELL I DON'T WANT
TO BELABOR THIS BECAUSE THIS IS
SUPPOSED TO BE AN OVERVIEW BUT
I HOPE YOU CONTINUE TO HAVE
THESE CONVERSATIONS BECAUSE
THERE ARE SOME AMIDST THIS
MONKS DOES- PERHAPS MAYBE THAT
WANT TO TAKE A SERIOUS LOOK AT
THIS ISSUE AS WE MEET ME MOVE
FORWARD. AND THISIF. IN THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION ARENA- I WILL
MENTION THAT THERE ARE THERE
ARE MECHANISMS THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY LOOKING AT AN OFFICE
THAT WOULD KIND OF AVOID
DISINCENTIVE ISSUES.
POTENTIALLY LOOKING AT HIGH A
HIGH COST RISK POOLS AND WHERE
IT WORKS ALMOST LIKE AN
INSURANCE MECHANISM. AND THAT
THE DISTRICT WOULD HAVE TO
SPEND A FAIR AMOUNT BEFORE IT
GETS QUALIFIES FOR PARTIAL
REIMBURSEMENT TO THIS FROM THE
STATE OR LOOKING AT POTENTIALLY
PROXY MEASURES DO NOT DIRECTLY-
FOCUSING AND FUNDING BASED ON
STUDENTS WITH MILD OR SEVERE
DISABILITIES. LOOKING AT
SOMETHING THAT IS KIND OF MORE
CHALLENGING THE GAME AND SO I
THINK THOSE ARE CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS DO YOU DO YOU
PLAN ON. PUTTING SOMETHING OUT
THAT SORT OF DETAILS SOME OF
THESE OPTIONS FOR US. I AM I
THINK IT IS GIVEN THE TIME LINE
IT'S MOST LIKELY THROUGH
CONVERSATIONS WITH. YOUR OFFICE
HAS GOT TO BE SUFFICIENT- BUT I
LOOK FORWARD TO. IF YOU'RE
HAVING THE PRODUCT OF THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD WITH THEIR
DELIBERATIONS HERE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR INPUT. MA'AM KRISTIN I
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION- I THINK JUST A DOVE
TAIL ON THE CONVERSATION YOU'RE
HAVING- WITH LA- IS THAT THAT
IT'S A IT'S ALSO AN AREA OF
INTEREST AROUND THIS IDEA OF
HOW KIDS ARE IDENTIFIED AND
WHAT CLASS OF WHAT CAN'T
DISABILITY CATEGORY THERE
IDENTIFIED UNDER BECAUSE NOT
ONLY DOES IT MAKE A DIFFERENCE
AROUND PERCEIVED FUNDING AN
ACTUAL FUNDING COSTS BUT ALSO
IN TERMS OF PERCEIVED OUTCOMES
AND SO IT'S AN AREA THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT- AND THAT WE LOOK AT
AROUND DISPROPORTIONATELY WHEN
YOU HAVE. CERTAIN MINORITY
STUDENT WORKS- THAT ARE OVER
REPRESENTED IN DIFFERENT
DISABILITY TYPES SO THERE'S A
LOT OF- THERE'S A LOT
UNDERNEATH THIS I THINK THE
FUNDING STUDY- FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND THAT SO THAT BEING
COMMISSIONED IS GOING TO BE
LOOKING AT- THESE HOW THESE
PLAY OUT AND I THINK THE FOLKS
THAT ARE DOING THE STUDY OF
JUSTIN AND STUDY OF ANOTHER
STATE TO REALLY LOOK THOSE
FORMULATIONS AND TO TRY TO AND
ASK SOME OF THAT SO THAT WE CAN
HAVE PERMISSION TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS. SO REALLY
LOOKING FORWARD AS WELL BECAUSE
THIS IS BEEN AN ONGOING
CONVERSATION ABOUT. IN A SYSTEM
THAT IS BASED ON LABELS WHAT
WE'RE REALLY AFTER IS TO TRY TO
GET STUDENTS WHAT THEY NEED
WHEN THEY NEED IT AND THAT- THE
MORE LABELS WERE PUTTING ON
STUDENTS. THE LESS YOU HAVE
ACCESS TO THINGS THAT WE'RE
SEEING THAT ACROSS ALL OF OURS
SORT OF INTERCONNECTED SYSTEMS
EVEN CROSSED DEPARTMENTS WELL
WE DO A LOT OF STUDIES ARE YES
HE HAS AND- I'M NOT SURE THAT
WE- DO MUCH WITH THE STUDIES
THAT WE- COMMISSION. A WOULD BE
ONE THING TO ME IF ALL THE
PLACES ON THE CHESS BOARD WERE
FULL ON WERE SIMPLY MOVING
PIECES AROUND BUT WE ARE
WORKING WITH A CHESS BOARD IT'S
GOT HALF THE PIECES ON IT AND
DISTRICTS ARE HAVING TO TAKE
THIS MONEY OUT OF SOME PLACE
AND SO I YOU KNOW I'M IN FAVOR
OF MOVING. FORWARD RATHER THAN
NECESSARILY WAITING FOR STUDIES
WE'RE DEALING WITH
PROFESSIONALS IN THE EDUCATION
ARENA AND YOU WOULD. I WOULD
CERTAINLY HOPE THAT.
PROFESSIONALS MAKE THE
DECISIONS THEY MAKE FOR THE
RIGHT REASONS AND NOT SIMPLY
TO. PUT A FEW MORE DOLLARS INTO
THE GENERAL FUND ACCOUNT TO DO
WITH WHATEVER. AND I'M I'M
LEARNING THAT YOU KNOW YOU.
THERE ARE VARIATIONS AND
APPARENTLY NOT EVERYTHING IS
CERTAIN AND FIXED IN THE AREA
OF SPECIAL EDUCATION AND- IN
THE IN THE CLASSIFICATIONS IN
THE CATEGORIES AND HOW WE-
ALLOCATE MONEY BUT I THINK WE
NEED TO TRY TO DO A BETTER JOB
AND FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE WE
NEED TO TRY TO DRIVE MORE MONEY
DOWN. TO ADDRESS- I NEED SO
THAT WE IN THE DEBT THE
DISTRICT LEVEL AND IN THE
CLASSROOM WE TAKE CARE OF. US
SOME OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
STUDENTS IN OUR STATE. AND OF
COURSE WE'RE EXTREMELY
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT SO YES
PLEASE I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND HOPEFULLY
YOU'RE GOING TO JOIN IN THE
CONVERSATION WITH THE LA- IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
ADMINISTRATION AND- WHAT'S THE
BEST WAY FORWARD HERE- IN A
SYSTEM WHERE THERE'S JUST NOT
ENOUGH MONEY IN THE PIPELINE.
MAY I ADD ONE MORE THING JUST
ROOM- THAT IS THAT. THAT THE
SIGNALS THAT WE'VE SEEN OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS THANK YOU TO
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND FINANCE
FOR RECOGNIZING ALL THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION TASK FORCE THAT HAD.
BEEN COMMISSION AND A NUMBER OF
YEARS AGO AND A LOT OF THE
THINGS THAT WERE. RECOMMENDED
IN THAT CAME ABOUT THROUGH
RESEARCH- HAVE ARE BEING
ADDRESSED IN AND- I WOULD SAY
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION IS
COMPLEX THAT ARE. EACH AND-
EACH AND EVERYONE OF OUR INTO
INDIVIDUAL STUDENTS ARE OUR
SYSTEM. FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
AND MEETING THE NEEDS OF THE
STUDENT IS VERY COMPLEX AND SO.
THIS SORT OF MULTIFACETED
APPROACH TO TRYING TO. FIX THE
SYSTEM IF YOU WILL- IS
ACTUALLY. WHAT WE SEE IS THE
RIGHT APPROACH ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT. THE
TEACHER ASPECT AND I THINK I
JUST WANNA IT SORT OF IN THIS
PIECE WITH SAYING THAT- IN ALL
OF OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
DISTRICTS. AND WHAT WE HEAR
WE'RE TRYING TO. IMPROVE OUR
PROCESSES WITH THEM AS THEIR
MORE MATURE THAN THAT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDER. IT REALLY
COMES DOWN TO THE VERY FIRST
TEACHING AND WHETHER OR NOT AS
A STATE WE'RE PUTTING IN PLACE.
A FUNDAMENTAL SYSTEM OF
UNIVERSAL DESIGN FOR LEARNING
IN EVERY CLASSROOM AND REALLY
SETTING THAT STANDARD FOR. THAT
SPECIAL EDUCATION CAN BE BUILT.
AS A SUPPLEMENT NOT SUPPLANTING
EDUCATION. SO WHAT WE'RE AFTER
IS SUPPORT THE- AND THE PARENT
EDUCATOR AND THE FAMILY. SO
THAT EVERYONE CAN WORK TOGETHER
AND THEN. EDUCATE CAN COME IN A
SORT OF. IT ACT EXPERTISE THE
NEW. A FEW WELL WHO WILL HELP
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL.
KNOWLEDGE IN. TO LIVE ANY FOR
THE QUESTION. WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
THANK YOU FOR WHAT YOU DO HAVE
DONE AND CONTINUE TO DO IN
THIS- VERY VERY IMPORTANT- AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION
WITH YOU. SO BRIDGES. THIS.
NEXT ITEM ISSUE NUMBER THREE
PERSPECTIVES ON SPECIAL
EDUCATION CHALLENGES. THANK YOU
FOR CONTINUING IN THAT RUNNING
AWAY YES MA'AM WOULD YOU
IDENTIFY YOURSELF FOR THE
RECORD PLEASE. DIRECTOR OR
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE THANK
YOU DIRECTOR FOR THE CALVARY
COLLABORATIVE FOR EDUCATIONAL
EXCELLENCE IN PARTICULAR MY
WORK IS IN PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO DISTRICTS ARE
STRUGGLING WITH SOME COMPLEX
AND CHALLENGING INSTRUCTIONAL
ISSUES THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
OKAY WHO WANTS 2% INTERESTING
OKAY. COMING AROUND TO YOU NOW
IS A COUPLE PIECES OF
INFORMATION- TO SORT OF LAY A
FOUNDATION IN TERMS OF WHAT WE
ARE WORKING ON IT FOCUSING ON
COLLECTIVELY AND WHEN I SAY
COLLECTIVELY I MEAN THIS IS AN
ALL HANDS ON DECK APPROACH IN
THE STATE AROUND ADDRESSING THE
ISSUES AROUND STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES THAT HAVE BEEN A
LONG TIME STANDING ISSUE FOR US
SO IF YOU LOOK AT AND IF YOU
HAVE IT BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE
FIRST- SORT OF SLIDE YOU'LL SEE
SOME SOME. LINES COLOR LINES
AND THE FIRST THAT OUR- OF OUR
STUDENTS WITHOUT DISABILITIES.
AND THE DOTTED SAID OUR OUR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES. AND
BASICALLY IT'S SHOWING THE
ACHIEVEMENT DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
STUDENTS. WHO ARE IN DIFFERENT.
ETHNIC GROUPS WHO DO OR DO NOT
HAVE DISABILITY SO ALL POINT
YOU TO- WHAT WE SEE IS IN THE
STRAIGHT LINES IS OR THE FILLED
OUT LINES THAT ARE NOT DOT THEY
DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW TO DESCRIBE
THAT. IS THAT THERE IS THAT
THAT IS THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP. OF
THAT WE SEE BETWEEN- GROUPS IF
YOU LOOK DOWN TO THE DOTTED
LINES THAT'S THE ADDITIONAL
ACHIEVEMENT GAP SO THIS IS THIS
IS OUR STUDENTS- WITH AND
WITHOUT DISABILITIES AGAIN. AND
OUR STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS. OVERALL
YOU'LL SEE THAT- THAT THE
DOTTED LINE IN YELLOW IS
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES. AND THAT'S THAT'S
THE GAP THAT YOU'RE SEEING
BETWEEN THEM. AND SOME OF THEIR
COUNTERPARTS- WITHOUT
DISABILITIES AND I BRING THAT
TO YOUR ATTENTION AND ALSO TO
THE TO LOOK AT THE FOLLOWING
SLIDE BELOW IT. WHICH SHOWS
WHERE STUDENTS ARE SPENDING
THEIR TIME. AND SO AS A STATE
WE RANK- IN THE- THE LAST
QUARTILE UP OR THE LOWEST
QUARTILE AROUND ACCESS FOR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES TO
THE GENERAL AT CLASSROOM. AND
ONE OF THE GOALS UNDER THE
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
EDUCATION ACT. IS FOR STUDENTS
TO SPEND THE MAJORITY OF THEIR
TIME WITH THEIR GENERAL APPEARS
RECEIVING GREAT FIRST
INSTRUCTION. AND SO AS A STATE
WERE ABOUT AT 56% OF OUR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
SPENDING BE PERCENT OR MORE OF
THEIR TIME IN GENERAL EDUCATION.
AND WE'D LIKE TO SEE THAT- TO
BE WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT
INCREASE SIGNIFICANTLY AND WE
JUST- CONVENED A STAKEHOLDER
GROUP WHICH WHERE IS UNDER OUR
REQUIREMENTS UNDER THE FEDERAL
ACT- WHO BASICALLY- SAID THAT
THEY WOULD LIKE US TO SEE. TE
CS GO UP ALMOST TWENTY
PERCENTAGE POINTS OVER THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS AROUND ACCESS. TO
THAT GENERAL EDUCATION
ENVIRONMENT. SO I BRING THAT TO
YOUR ATTENTION BECAUSE WE
OUTCOMES ARE DIRECTLY RELATED
WHETHER OR NOT STUDENTS ARE
ABLE TO READ AND COMMUNICATE
AND EXPRESS THEMSELVES AND- GET
ACCESS TO THE GRADE LEVEL
STANDARDS. SO THAT. A LOT OF
THE DEEP WORK THAT WE'RE DOING
IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CLAPPER FOR
EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE AS WELL
AS OUR COUNTY OFFICES AND
DISTRICTS IS AROUND HOW DO WE
GIVE KIDS MORE. TIME WITH THAT
GREAT FIRST TEACHER IN THEIR
GENERAL AYE CLASSROOM WITH
THEIR PEERS. AND IN THAT HOW DO
WE HAVE HOW WILL WE MAKE SURE
TO INCREASE THEIR READING- AND
COMMUNICATION PROFICIENCY
LEVELS SO THAT THEY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET THAT HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA TO MOVE ON. WELL
BY THE WAY HOW WOULD GRADE
WOULD YOU GIVE THIS IF YOU.
GRADING I MEAN I'M LOOKING AT
THE TOP CHART. AND WHILE THE
SCALE MAY BE. DECEPTIVE YOU
KNOW IF YOU. IT IT IT ALMOST
LOOKS LIKE A FLAT LINE EVEN
THOUGH IT REALLY ISN'T IN IN
ALL LEVELS YEAH. AND N. AS TO
THE- AT LEAST RESTRICTIVE ISSUE
I MEAN THIS IS AN AREA WHERE-
CELL PRISON AND ELEAZAR YOU
HAVE TO PROVIDE THE SERVICE.
RIGHT WHETHER YOU TAKE IT
WHETHER WE FUNDED ARE THE FEDS
FUND IS RIGHT FOR YOU FUNDED
OUT OF YOUR- GENERAL FUND SO
IT'S NOT A IT'S NOT A MONEY I
MEAN IT'S A MONEY ISSUE IN
TERMS OF THE COST OF THE- HIT.
THE GENERAL FUND FOR THESE
DISTRICTS. BUT THE MONEY. HAS
TO BE THERE FOR STUDENTS WHO
NEED THE SERVICES RIGHT SO
GIVEN THE FACT THAT THE MONEY'S
THERE AND IT'S NOT A MONEY
FUNDING ISSUE. HOW DO WE
ACCOUNT FOR THE FOR A- FOR THE
DIFFERENCE FOR EXAMPLE IN THE
LEAST RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENT
STATISTIC. AND HOW ARE WE TO
PORT AND HOW DO WE ACCOUNT FOR
THE FAILURE TO MAKE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS BETWEEN FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN AND- EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
IN THE PROFICIENCY AREA. THE
CENTER FOR QUESTION IT IS IT IS
A QUESTION AND I THINK IT'S A
QUESTION THAT ARE THAT THAT'S
SORT OF THE ALL HANDS ON DECK
APPROACH IS- FIRST WE HAVE TO
HAVE A- GREAT FIRST TEACHING
WITH YOU KNOW AND GIVE OUR
EDUCATORS THE KIND OF
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED IN ORDER
TO DO THEIR BEST WORK. AND BUT
I THINK WE WOULD ARGUE THAT
IT'S HARD TO IT'S HARD TO ARGUE
THAT KIDS WITH DISABILITIES CAN
GET ACCESS TO THAT IF THEY'RE
NOT THERE. IF THEY'RE IN
SEPARATE SETTINGS- AND NOT WITH
THEIR GENERAL APPEARS BECAUSE
WHAT WE'RE MAPPING TO HEAR IS
EMPLOYMENT AND COMMUNITY
INCLUSION BELONGING FOR EVERY
SINGLE STUDENT OUR STATE AND
WHAT WHAT ACCOUNTS FOR THE
DIFFERENCE FOR AND FOR NOT
MAINSTREAMING AS OPPOSED. SOBRE
DAY SO EACH OF THOSE. EACH OF
THE EACH OF THIS IS A
COMPILATION OF INDIVIDUAL
STUDENT. YOU KNOW EDUCATION
PROGRAMS RIGHT SO THIS IS THE
INDIVIDUAL STUDENT ENTITLEMENT.
SO EVERY THE PERFORMANCE ISSUE
SOMEWHERE DOWN IN THEBOWELS OF
THE DEATH OF THE DISTRICTS
INVOLVED. AS OPPOSED TO THE
AVAILABILITY OF RESOURCE. I
THINK IT'S BOTH I THINK IT'S A
COMBINATION OF THINGS RIGHT SO
IF YOU IF OUR STUDENTS. FIRST
OF ALL NEED TO BE INCLUDED IN
GENERAL AND- THEN THAT'S GONNA
THAT TAKES A LEVEL OF SUPPORT.
FOR THE TEACHER IN THE
CLASSROOM- IT ALSO IT TOUCHES
ON SO MANY DIFFERENT THINGS ALL
THE WAY FROM TRAINING AND SO
YOU KNOW WE CAN PUT WE CAN PULL
OUT THE IDEA AROUND- SPECIAL A
TEACHER SHORTAGE. AND HAVING A
SEASON TEACHER- ASSIGNED TO
EACH OF THOSE STUDENTS RIGHT WE
MAY HAVE. TEACHERS IN THEIR
FIRST YEAR OR TEACHERS ON SO
THEY'RE SPENDING THE MONEY IT'S
JUST THEY'RE NOT RIGHT IT WILL
TO SPEND THE MONEY ON THE TOOLS
THE MOST AFFECTED. SO THE
QUESTION IS AND THIS IS WHAT WE
GRAPPLE WITH ALL THE TIME IS
HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU BUILD UP
CAPACITY IN THE STATE I THINK
IT CAME UP EARLIER AROUND THE-
THE CONTRACTING IN THAT. YOU
ASKED A QUESTION ABOUT
CONTRACTING. WE DO HAVE TO
BUILD THAT CAPACITY IN OUR
SCHOOLS FOR THEM WE THEY NEED
ENOUGH MONEY TO BE ABLE TO
SUSTAIN. A SO THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE TO CONTRACT OUT BECAUSE
THE REALITY IS THEY HAVE TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICE ANYWAY.
RIGHT BECAUSE IT'S AN
INDIVIDUAL ENTITLEMENT BE SUED.
THE SPENDING THE MONEY THE
QUESTION IS ARE THEY SPENDING
THE MONEY IN THE MOST EFFECTIVE
WAY I GUESS AND AS OF ARE YOU
RIGHT AND SO WE WANT THEM TO
GET IN THE CYCLE WHERE THEY'RE
BUILDING THEIR OWN DISTRICT
CAPACITY THAT'S A LOT OF THE
WORK THE CARLA AS TO- AROUND.
BEING ABLE TO HAVE THOSE KINDS
OF ONE WELL SUPPORTED
CLASSROOMS AND WELL SUPPORTED
ADMINISTRATORS WHO ARE HIGHLY
TRAINED TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THE INSTRUCTIONAL PROGRAMS FOR
TEACHERS TO DO THEIR BEST WORK
AND FOR. AND SO PART OF THIS IS
IT'S A MINDSET AND MENTAL MODEL
PROBLEM THAT WE'VE CLASSICALLY
HAD STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
EXCLUDED. SO PART OF THIS IS.
YOU KNOW. AN ACCEPTANCE WHERE
WE WANT TO INCLUDE STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES BECAUSE IT'S
THERE YOU KNOW IT'S THEIR RIGHT
AS PEOPLE TO BE INCLUDED. AND
WE ALSO KNOW THAT TRACKS
DIRECTLY IF YOU START OFF IN AN%
AS IN A SEGREGATED BETTING IN
PRESCHOOL YOU TYPICALLY END IN
THE SEGREGATED SETTING IN
SCHOOL OFTEN DON'T RECEIVE HER
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA. SO FOR
BACKWARD MAPPING FROM WHAT WE
WANT FOR OUR STUDENTS WERE WE
WANT THEM TO START FROM THE
BEGINNING TO KNOW THAT THEY
BELONG AND THEN TO BUILD IN ALL
THOSE LEVELS OF SUPPORT THE FOR
SOME STUDENTS THAT'S A LOT OF
SUPPORT. YOU KNOW FOR MY
DAUGHTER THAT MAY MEAN. SHE
NEEDS FULL TIME. WORKING ALL
THE TIME TO INCLUDE HER IN THAT
CLASSROOM MAYBE EVEN MORE THAN
ONE PERSON. BUT THAT WOULD BE
THE MORE SIGNIFICANT END OF THE
SPECTRUM AND WE GET THERE. SO
IT MAY NOT IS THIS HOW DOES
THIS SURE HOW DOES THIS. THAT
IS HOW DO WE GET THERE BECAUSE
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
INCREASED FUNDING- IN
PARTICULAR AREAS. RELIEVING IN
THEIR SPENDING THIS THE BOTTOM
OF THEIR PRESUMABLY SPENDING
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THEY NEED
TO SPEND OR THEY WOULD BE SUED.
ON SPECIAL EDUCATION BECAUSE IS
A REQUIREMENT TO DO SO AND YOU
KNOW IF THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE
PROBABLY IN LITIGATION SOME
DISTRICT BUNCH OF. AND WE CAN
REARRANGE THE MONEY TO TRY TO
GET IT TO THE HIGH COST AREAS
AND SHOULD. BUT WITHIN THAT
ENVIRONMENT WHATEVER THE MONEY
IS HOPEFULLY IT'S ENOUGH HOW DO
WE IMPROVE PERFORMANCE. AT THE
SCHOOL LEVEL. WHAT'S THE
PROCESS TO DO THAT. I MEAN DO
WE SEND OUT TEAMS OF INSPECTORS
AND SAY TO THE SUPERINTENDENT
AND THE PRINCIPLE. NO NO NO HI
SO HOW DO WE DO IT IF AND
FRANKLY JUST GIVE UP I DON'T
MEAN TO NO I THINK THE I THE
RIGHT CUT IS THAT IS THAT IT
BUT IT IS A COMBINATION OF MANY
ISSUES AND ONE OF THEM IS A
FUNDING ISSUE AND SO FOR IF WE
WANT THE IF WE WANT TO.
DISTRICTS BE ABLE TO BUILD UP
ALL THEIR- FUNDAMENTAL HERE ONE
BEST FIRST INSTRUCTION AND THE
MANDATE IS ON MAKING SURE TO
PROVIDE ALL THE RELATED
SERVICES IN THERE AND THERE'S
NOT ENOUGH MONEY THERE THAN
THAT. MANDATE IT COMES TO THE
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES FOR
THOSE SERVICES BECAUSE THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT IS REQUIRED AND
YOU'RE RIGHT THEY WILL BE
LITIGATED BUT I THINK CARL CAN
SPEAK TO. MAKE IT TO THE
FUNDING ISSUE BECAUSE I'M SO
FASCINATED BY IT SO EVEN IF WE
PROVIDE AN OVERLAY TO THE V.
SIX A TWO FOUR FORMULA FOR THE
MODERN SEVERELY DISABLED.
STUDENTS IN WEEKS HELLO THAT
DOWN THE PIPELINE TO THE
SUBURBS IN THE ALLEYS. IT COSTS
MUCH ANYWAY THE DEAD RELEASE
PRESSURE ON THE GENERAL FUND
RIGHT. SO THEY ARE GETTING MORE
MONEY FROM US PRESUMABLY THEY
DON'T HAVE TO TAKE AS MUCH OF
THE GENERAL FUND. TO COVER THE
COST OF SPECIAL EDUCATION IN
THE DISTRICTS. ARE WE ASSUMING
THAT THEY'RE GONNA. TAKE THE
MONEY THAT WE HAVE. THE
OBLIGATION THAT WE HAVE
SOMEWHAT RELIEVED THEM FROM IN
TERMS OF THERE'S GENERAL FUND.
AND THEY'RE GOING TO KEEP THAT
GENERAL FUND MONEY MOVING
TOWARDS SPECIAL ED. I THINK
WE'RE MAKING THE ASSUMPTION
THOUGH THAT THE FOUNDATION
AROUND UNIVERSAL EDUCATION FOR
ALL IF YOU LOOK AT THE DATA FOR
EXAMPLE YOU'RE SAYING THAT IT'S
NOT JUST STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES BUTTRESSING OVER
ON THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
STUDENT PERFORMANCE IN LA AND
MATHEMATICS ARE AREAS THAT WE
HAVE GREAT IMPROVEMENT THAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN. SO I DO THINK
THINK ABOUT HOW WE FIND JUST
ENSURING THAT THE GOOD FIRST
TEACHING. IS OCCURRING IN EVERY
CLASSROOM IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS SOMETHING THAT
AROUND PER PEOPLE FUNDING WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO THINK ABOUT. WHAT
WOULD THAT TAKE WHAT IS THAT
LOOK LIKE- BECAUSE THEN YOU CAN
LOOK AT SPECIAL EDUCATION
FUNDING AND SERVICES. OKAY THEN
WHAT THESE. SELECT FOR OUR
STUDENTS WITH. HOW DO YOU IT
WAS THAT HOW IN SAN. THAT
WITHIN THE SUBURB WITHIN THE
ELLIE A FOR EXAMPLE. IN MY
EXPERIENCE ARE FINDING AS WE
WORK AND PROVIDING DIRECT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND AS THE
AS THE DISTRICT- AND PLAY FOR A
LONG TIME. WHAT I'M FINDING IS
THAT FOLKS IN MANY SITUATIONS
DO UNDERSTAND WHAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN. I THINK THERE'S A
COUPLE AREAS WHERE THE
STRUGGLES BEGAN WINDING IS HOW
DO YOU BEGIN TO BUILD A
CONSENSUS ABOUT LOCAL LEVEL ON
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE SO WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT EDUCATING ALL KIDS.
EACH COMMUNITY HAS ITS OWN VIEW
AND WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE AND SO
HOW DO YOU WORK WITH PEOPLE TO
CREATE GOOD STRONG PLANS OF
ACTIONS WITH SOME BENCHMARKS.
KNOWING THAT THAT WORKS WILL
NOT WORKING AND BEING ABLE TO
COURSE CORRECT IT'S SOMETHING
THAT DISTRICTS ARE STILL TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE ABLE
TO DO. THE NEXT PIECE THOUGH
AND THE REPORTING OUT TO
PUBLIC. BECAUSE PUBLIC HEALTH
CAP FOR EXAMPLE RIGHT WE KNOW
THAT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
SHOULD BE REALLY DRIVING THE
STRATEGIC INITIATIVES WITHIN
THE DISTRICT. BUT DISTRICTS
STILL ARE REALLY TRYING TO BE
REFLECTIVE OF HOW TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT JURY STILL OUT ON
WHETHER THAT WORKS OR IS THIS
PART OF THE DASHBOARD FOR
EXAMPLE I MEAN YOU CAN BEING
RESPONSIVE TO THE DASHBOARD
DATA IS ONE OF THOSE THINGS
THAT. BUT IN THIS AREA SO YEAH
HE'LL ACTUALLY 57% OF OUR
DISTRICTS THAT ARE- QUALIFY FOR
DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE.
UNDER THE DASHBOARD FOR THEIR
WHAT THEIR DATA IS TELLING US
IS FOR THE STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES. GROUP SO THAT'S
WHY I'M SAYING IT IS THIS
THERE'S ALL NAMES ON. EFFORT
THERE IS A DEEP CONNECTION
BETWEEN THAT GOOD FIRST
INSTRUCTION AND THEN WHAT
HAPPENS. AFTER BECAUSE
TECHNICALLY EVERY STUDENT AS A
GENERAL AT STUDENT THERE'S NOT
SPECIAL ED STUDENTS IN GENERAL
ITS STUDENTS THEIR STUDENTS
THAT ARE THEIR STUDENTS THEN
THEIR STUDENTS WHO ALSO RECEIVE
SPECIAL EDUCATION. AND SO WE
THAT'S THE PIECE THAT WERE
REALLY TRYING TO. MEMORIALIZE
OF YELLOW I WAS THE SECOND
PIECE OF THAT IS ALSO THE
TECHNICAL SYSTEMS TO WELL TO
SUPPORT ON THE GROUND. SO IN
THE CLASSROOM THE STUDENTS YEAR
EVERY YEAR EVERY DAY THEIR
CONSTANT. IN THE SYSTEM IT'S A
NEAT. GILLES BILL TO PRESS.
CONTEMPLATING SO THE TYPES OF
THE ARTS AVAIL OKAY. AT FROM.
THE CLOSEST SINCE STATE WHY
TECHNO SYSTEMS ALSO A LOCAL LAW.
IS SOMETHING THAT CAN NEEDS BE
ABLE TO GROW AND CHANGE BECAUSE
THAT KIND OF COACHING AND
IMPLEMENTATION. IS REALLY WHAT
DRIVES THE CHANGE IT'S WHAT
TEACHERS AND FEEL LIKE I HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO DO THIS I CAN
DO THIS WHAT ARE THE SUPPORT
SENATE DISTRICT NEEDS TO BE
AWARE OF IN UNDERSTAND THAT.
SHIFTING NEEDS NEED ALSO THEM
TO BE ABLE TO SHIFT. THOSE KIND
THAT KIND OF SUPPORT TO KNOW
HOW TO DO THAT. IS NOT AN EASY
THING TO BE ABLE TO DO WITHOUT
SOME TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
SUPPORT. I THINK ONE OF THINGS
I SEE IT ON IS AROUND LIKE
CREEK BEING ABLE TO CREATE
CONTINUUM'S OF SUPPORT THROUGH
MULTI TIERED SYSTEMS- BEHAVIOR
IS ONE OF THOSE AREAS SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO BUILD A
CULTURE AND CLIMATE AT A SCHOOL
THAT REALLY FEELS WELCOMING AND
SAFE. AND AT THE SAME TIME BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT KIND OF
INDIVIDUALIZED SUPPORT FOR
CERTAIN STUDENTS AND FAMILIES.
HOW DOES ONE SCHOOL BE ABLE TO
OFFER THAT HOW DOES ONE
DISTRICT BILL THAT- THIS IS WHY
SOMETIMES I'VE SEEN FOR EXAMPLE
COSTS. AROUND THESE KINDS OF
CONTINUUM'S OF SUPPORT. OF
BECOME QUIT THEIR PRIMARY BIG
IN THE REASON WHY THE PEOPLE
REALLY FEELING IT AT THE
DISTRICT LEVEL IS BECAUSE-
BEING ABLE TO BUILD THAT KIND
OF CONTINUING CANNOT JUST BE ON
ONE END OF. INDIVIDUALIZED
SUPPORT IT ALSO HAS TO BE
PROACTIVE IT ALSO HAS TO BE FOR
THE MANY KIDS WALKING TO THE
GATE OF THE SCHOOL THAT THEY'RE
FEELING THAT. TEACHERS YOU KNOW
AND THEN- SUPPORT STAFF AS WELL
AS PRINCIPLES ARE ABLE TO
REALLY WORK TOGETHER TO ENSURE
THAT THESE KIDS ARE READY TO GO
FROM THE MINUTE THEY WALK INTO
THE SCHOOL AND- REALLY MOVE
OUTSIDE THE- THIS. I WILL HAVE
BEEN FOCUSED ON TODAY WHICH IS
THE SILO AND AT LEAST IN PART.
THE SILO INVOLVING SOCIAL
CATION FUNDING YOU MOVE INTO.
FOR AND GENERALLY. A LIST THE
CASE TWELVE EDUCATE WHETHER.
THE MEANT. FOR THE LAST. GEN
FIVE SUN THE YOU LOOK AT THE-
IF THE SECOND. GROW OF THE
SECOND GRAPH. REALLY WHAT
THAT'S US IS KIND OF WHAT WE'RE
TO ABOUT WHICH IS R. C. WITH
DISABILITIES ARE NOT JUST USE
WHICH IS A FOR THEY EARNED
DOLLARS AS GENERAL AS STUDENTS
RIGHT WE'RE NOT JUST- SAYING
THERE SOON WITH THIS BUILDING
AND CHARGING EVERYTHING AGAIN
SPECIAL ED RIGHT. GET THAT THEY
REALLY ARE ENTITLED TO THOSE
AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE A HIGHER
NUMBER OF OUR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES REPRESENTED IN OUR
FOSTER YOUTH- IT WITH OUR
ENGLISH LEARNERS AND ALSO WITH
OUR STUDENTS THAT RECEIVE
RECEIVE FREE AND REDUCED PRICE
MEALS. SO OVERALL MORE 70% OF
OUR STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
ARE IN ONE OR MORE OF THOSE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
STUDENT GROUPS AS WELL. MEANING
THAT THIS IS ALL SO
INTERCONNECTED AND IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT GETTING SPECIAL
LOWER YOU KNOW THIS IS ABOUT AN
ALL HANDS ON DECK EFFORT ABOUT.
WHAT WE BELIEVE IN KIDS- THAT
IT'S EACH AND EVERY KID AND
THAT WERE REALLY THE- DISTRICT
THAT WERE WORKING WITH THAT
WE'VE SEEN. SO MUCH IMPROVEMENT
OVER TIME- WITH GENERATION
RATES FOR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES AND OTHER THINGS
ARE REALLY THE ONES THAT HAVE
INTENTIONALLY BACKWARD MAPPED.
TO PRESCHOOL. AND STARTED WITH
A SHIFT IN MINDSET AND MENTAL
MODELS ABOUT WHAT THEY BELIEVE
ABOUT ALL KIDS. AND THAT
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES ARE
NOT. KIDS WHO CAN'T LEARN SINCE
THE DISABILITIES ARE KIDS WITH
UNIQUE LEARNING NEEDS THAT YOU
KNOW WHAT TO DO ABOUT. THE
SYSTEM AND SO PART OF THAT IT
INTO CARLOS WHEN IT'S WE'RE
JUST WE'RE JUST. SEEING THAT WE
NEED TO PROVIDE A LOT OF
SUPPORT AND SO ALL THESE
DIFFERENT PIECES OF THE
STATEWIDE IN IT AND THE SHOULD
HAVES AND THE BUDGET PROPOSALS.
ALL SPEAK TO PIECES OF THAT SO
IT'S JUST LIKE REALLY
COMPLICATED PUZZLE. THAT WE ARE
STARTING TO I THINK IT HAS THE
MOMENTUM ON BUT WE NEED TO
KEEP. DOING OKAY YEAH. I AND
GET CLOSER AND CLOSER TO THOSE
CLASSROOMS I THINK WHAT I'M
FINDING ARE ARE THINGS LIKE
WITHIN THE STATE SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT WE START TO IDENTIFY
SOME CONTENT LEADS AROUND
SPECIAL EDUCATION AREAS. OF
REAL NEED THAT AS AS PRESENT AS
HIGHLIGHTED PERFORMANCE
INDICATORS ISSUE A WEEK WE'VE
GOT WORK TO DO. AND SO WE HAVE
AREAS LIKE ENGLISH LEARNERS
THAT ARE ALSO STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES LOOKING AT ISSUES
OF DISPROPORTIONATE ALLEN HERE
WE OVER IDENTIFYING ARE UNDER
IDENTIFYING CERTAIN STUDENTS.
OR LOOKING AT IMPLEMENTING
SOMETHING SO IMPORTANT LIKE YOU
UNIVERSAL DESIGN FOR LEARNING-
WE ARE FINDING THAT THAT TYPE
OF TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IS
SOMETHING THAT DISTRICTS. LEDS
DO WANT AND BUT THEY ALSO NEED
EVEN DEEPER THEY WANT TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE FOLKS HO CAN
ACTUALLY COME TO THEIR- SCHOOL
BE ABLE TO. COME OUT TO THEIR
DISTRICT AND PROVIDE THAT
DIFFERENT TYPE OF SUPPORT AND
SO OTHER FUNDING AREAS ARE LIKE
YOU WE CAN SEE AS A LAY ALSO
BEGIN TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
BUILDING THAT CAPACITY FROM THE
ROOTS UP. AS WERE ALSO BUILDING
THAT TYPE OF TECHNICAL SYSTEMS
THAT FOLKS ARE JUST GONNA NEED
AS THEY TRY TO IMPLEMENT THEM.
I'M IMPORTANT BUT A VERY
COURAGEOUS WORK THAT THE TAP.
IS A BRAND TING IN THE SHIP IN.
SHE WERE ABLE TO HAPPEN ON CUT
IN GRANT GOT DOLLARS IN THE K.
CONCENTRATION GRANT DOLLARS ARE
READ THE STEW IN THIS THAT OF
THE GREATER NADER THEY'RE
SIMPLE ELSE AND THE HOLY ABOUT
THIS BETWEEN SCHOOL A IN SCHOOL
AND BECAUSE THEY PREDICT DOES
HAS YOU KNOW. THE 55% OVER 55%
ANSWERED CENTERS SO VERY
INTERESTING AND YOU DON'T KNOW
HOW OFTEN. YOU'RE ALWAYS THINK
ABOUT THE FACT THAT IT'S NOT
JUST TALKING ABOUT SPECIAL
EDUCATION DOLLARS. SENDING
THOSE DOWN A PIPELINE IT'S ALL
OF THE OTHER EDUCATION DOLLARS
THAT FLOW TO A PARTICULAR
SCHOOL CAMPUS. AND WHETHER
THOSE ARE SUFFICIENT TO PROVIDE
SERVICES THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO
THE EDUCATION OF A STUDENT WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS BUT ARE NOT
DIRECTLY RELATED- IN THE WAYS
THAT WE TYPICALLY THINK ABOUT
AROUND. AND WE'RE CURRENTLY-
CONVICTING A WORKER RIGHT NOW
FROM THE BUDGET FROM SB SEVENTY
FIVE FROM WHAT. LAST BUDGET
CYCLE OF AROUND. FAQ TO- MEDI
CAL DOLLARS FOR SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH. AND ABSENCE IS ALSO A
BIG PART OF THAT CONVERSATION
BECAUSE THE STUDENTS THAT
YOU'RE SEEING IN THOSE GRAPHS
ARE ALSO THE ONES THAT WE CAN
DRAW DOWN DOLLARS FOR THE
SERVICES THAT THEY RECEIVE.
PROP SIXTY THREE MONEY AS WELL
BY THE WAY YES. SO THIS ALL
THIS IS SUCH AN INTERCONNECTED
CONVERSATION AND WHAT WERE
SENSING AND WE'RE BEEN PART OF
A LOT MORE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
HOW DO WE WORK COLLABORATIVELY
ACROSS- STATE DEPARTMENTS AND
FUNDING SOURCES TO BE ABLE TO
MAXIMIZE. HELPING OUR STUDENTS
WHERE THEY ARE WHEN THEY NEED
THE HELP. PERFECT YEAH. IF I
MAY DECIDE LATER ANOTHER GROUP
OF WORK THAT WE HAVE FOUND TO
BE REALLY HELPFUL SUCH AS
WORKING WITH DISTRICTS AND IT'S
BEEN NICE TO BE ABLE TO SAY
YOUR DATA SAYING THIS. HOW DO
WE MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE GETTING
YOU THE RIGHT SO YOU NEED TO BE
ABLE TO DO THIS WORK. HAVE BEEN
THINGS LIKE THAT THE PARTY
INCLUDES OF PRACTICES WERE AND
I WANT TO THANK THE CD E. FOR
MAKING THEMSELVES ALWAYS
AVAILABLE. BECAUSE WE KNOW THE
BEST WAY TO REALLY EDUCATE OUR
STUDENTS WITH THIS PLACE TO SEE
THE OUTCOMES WOULD LIKE TO SEE
OUR THROUGH INCLUSIONARY
PRACTICES. BUT IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT'S SO EASY TO
JUST BE ABLE TO TURN KIßM
MAKE HAPPEN. AND SO BEING ABLE
TO HAVE FOLKS LIKE TEAM INCOME
AT ALL AND WERE. THE DISK IN
THE SCHOOL. IT ANOTHER PER
EXAMPLE OF HOW WE FOLK THAT'S
THE KIND OF SUPPORT PEOPLE ARE
LOOKING TO BE ABLE TO ALSO SEE.
FROM THE STATE. BUT HOW DO WE-
MAYBE YOU MENTIONED THE SENATE.
BECAUSE I MOLD IT FLEW OVER MY
HEAD BUT- HOW DO YOU. HOW DO WE
THE DATA. THE BILL THAT. IN A-
GOOD WAY ABOUT THE NUNS ED.
IMPACT ON THE EDUCATION OF
THOSE WITH SPECIAL NEEDS ON THE
SCHOOL CAMPUS IS THAT A FAIR
QUESTION IT'S A FAIR QUESTION I
DO THINK ES WHAT IS I MEAN THIS
IS REGARDING THAT I MEAN IT'S A
RATHER GENERALIZED APPROACH. TO
AND I THINK THE THING THAT WILL
BE TRICKY THINGS IT'S A GOOD
QUESTION I THINK WHAT'S TRICKY
IS ALWAYS EACH PLACE IS SO
DIFFERENT AND TRIES TO DEFINE
THEIR PROGRAMMING IF I WAS JUST
AT A DISTRICT THAT WAS THE
FINING. TEACHING IN ONE WAY
WHEN ACTUALLY AS THE RESEARCH
AND OTHERS WOULD DEFINE IT IS
NOT NECESSARY PERFECTLY ALIGNED
AND SO WHERE WHERE DO YOU START
TO ALSO MAKE SURE THAT HOW
PEOPLE DESCRIBE CERTAIN
PROGRAMMING OR FRAMEWORKS
THEY'RE IMPLEMENTING. MAKING
SURE THAT THERE ARE- BEING
DESCRIBED IN THE SAME WAY SO
YOU CAN MEASURE WHETHER
SOMETHING IS ON THE ALLEGED
CATION SIDE OF MAKING SURE ALL
KIDS HAVE ACCESS IS THIS IDEA
OF. UNIVERSAL EDUCATION FOR ALL
OF VERSES THOSE THINGS THAT
REALLY SHOULD BE UNIQUE AND
SPECIALIZED TWOS YES WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS SO WHAT'S SPECIAL
ABOUT SPECIAL EDUCATION. RIGHT
ABOUT COORDINATING THEY CARE
AND SERVICES WERE PROVIDING.
THE WE HAVE A LOT OF ENTITIES
EVEN AMONGST THOSE STUDENT
GROUPS THAT YOU SAW THE OVERLAP
IN WE'RE DOING AND THAT
INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF WORK
AROUND FOSTER YOUTH AND THE A
CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM. SO
MUCH OF THOSE. THOSE THE IT IS
AND SERVICES TIED TOGETHER SO
PART OF THIS IS THERE'S A LOT
OF WORK HAPPENING RIGHT NOW
ABOUT HOW TO HOW TO DO TRICKS
AND COUNT READ. WORKED FOR THIS
QUE THINKING WHAT AND BRING THE
TWO SO EVERYONE COULD NOT- YOU
KNOW WHAT YOU GO WONDER ARE.
AND BEHIND THAT DOOR ARE ALL OF
US COORDINATING THE SERVICE FOR
CHILD. SO IT'S NOT SO USING FOR
PEOPLE TO YOUR OUT CAN BECAUSE
THE LABEL BRING. THIS CALL. ON
THE- HELP THAT. WE'RE ALL AT
THE TABLE THANK BRING TO THE AS
AGENTS AND FALLERS TO HELP TO
SUPPORT THAT SAME WHO'S IN THE
OVER BIG. CONTRIBUTING TO THE
OVERALL PER OF OURS RIGHT SO
EACH IF YOU LOOK AT JUST FROM
OF PERSPECTIVE OUR STUDENTS WHO
ARE THE LOWEST IF YOU'RE
AVERAGING YOU'RE HAVING THAT A
LOT OF KIDS WHO ARE REALLY LOW
THAN OUR OVERALL STATE IS IT
LOWER RATE BUT THERE ARE SOME
KIDS WHO EAT WHO ARE ERROR.
COULD REALLY SUPPORT AND I
WOULD SAY FOR SPECIAL ED WE
KNOW THAT IT'S NOT. CASSIDY
ISSUE. A LOT OF TIMES AT THE
TIME ISSUE FOR MEASUREMENT IS
USUALLY VERY SPECIFIC IN TIME
LIKE YOU HAVE FOUR YEARS TO DO
THIS OR YOU NEED TO READ BY
THIS TIME. SOMETIMES IT TAKES A
LITTLE LONGER BUT IT DOESN'T
MEAN IT CAN'T HAPPEN. AND SO I
THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITY RIGHT NOW TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE THINGS
PARTICULARLY AROUND THAT THE
TEACHING ASPECT AND THE EARLY
INTERVENTION PIECES- THEY WERE
TALKING ABOUT I THINK THIS LIKE
CNX ABOUT. THAT DOVETAILS INTO
THE CONVERSATION WAS VERY
INTERESTING CONVERSATION.
HITTING US THAT'S IT THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR COMING TO
PARTICIPATE I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION
I'LL TELL YOU THIS. HAVING DONE
OTHER THINGS FOR SIX YEARS
INCOMING STEPPING INTO THE
EDUCATION ARENA. THE NUMBER
PROGRAM IT'S NO WONDER WE HAVE
DIFFICULTY COORDINATING ALL
VALUABLE THE NUMBER OF PROGRAMS
COMING TO A PROBLEM DIFFERENT
DIRECTIONS. MY OF TO AND
EVERYONE OF YOU WORK IN THE
AREA WHO CAN KEEP IT ALL
STRAIGHT SO. THANK YOU FOR WHAT
YOU DO. INSTEAD OF. YEAH THANK
YOU FOR NOT RUNNING ANY ANY
OTHER PERSON THE RUN AWAY BY
NOW THE NEXT PANEL IS THE
CALIFORNIA DYSLEXIA INITIATIVE
PROPOSAL IT'S ISSUE NUMBER FOR
OUR FINAL ISSUE IN THE
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING TODAY.
THANK YOU ALL FOR COMING BACK I
RECOGNIZE FAMILIAR FACES WHO
WANTS TO START. I'M SATISFIED
HI AGAIN MICHELLE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THEM. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES FOUR
MILLION ONE TIME ABOUT NINETY
EIGHT FOR DYSLEXIA RESEARCH
TRAINING AND A STATEWIDE
CONFERENCE- THIS PROPOSAL IS
REALLY AIMED AT BUILDING
CAPACITY AND SHARING BEST
PRACTICES AROUND DYSLEXIA
SCREENING AND INTERVENTIONS-
THE CALIFORNIA DYSLEXIA
GUIDELINES WHICH WERE FIRST
RELEASED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO
THE HARD WORK OF. THE
DEPARTMENT OF ADD A LOT OF
RESEARCHERS MODESTE. AB
PROVIDED EXTENSIVE INFORMATION
ON BEST PRACTICES FOR DYSLEXIA
SCREENING AND INTERVENTIONS-
HOWEVER THE CAUGHT THE
GUIDELINES WHEN THEY RELEASE
WHICH IS AN OPTIONAL RESOURCE
AND AT THE CALIFORNIA THE
CALIFORNIA DISLIKES INITIATIVE
IS REALLY AN OPPORTUNITY- AIMED
AT PROVIDING SUPPORT TO LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES USING ALL
THE RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE LIKE
THE DYSLEXIC GUIDELINES AND-
AND OTHER RESOURCES TO HELP.
STRUGGLING LEARNERS AND WE KNOW
THAT THERE'S A HIGH PROPORTION
OF STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
WHO HAVE SPECIFIC LEARNING
ABILITY DYSLEXIA OF WHICH IS
ONE OF THE MOST COMMON. I'M AND
REALLY DISTRICT. WHAT AND. BE
AND TO PAYING FOR UNIVERSAL
SCREENING AND JUST SUPPORT WITH
SHOPPING THERE. AND I BEHALF TO
TAKE QUESTIONS. NEXT ANYWAY
WITH LA OUT WE DON'T HAVE A
SPECIFIC. ON THIS PROPOSAL WE
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
VIEW THIS PROPOSAL IN THE SAME
LIGHT AS THE OTHER PROPOSED
SPECIAL EDUCATION WORK GROUPS
AND STUDIES AND EVALUATE
WHETHER THIS PROPOSAL MINDS
WITH LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES.
YES MA'AM KRISTIN RIGHT
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. WE ARE EXCITED TO
GET MOMENTUM AROUND- THIS THIS
INITIATIVE AND- SPECIFICALLY IN
ADDRESSING DYSLEXIA IT'S AN
AREA THAT WE ADDRESS BOTH IN
SPECIAL ED. AND FROM  GENERAL
AND ACTIVE- AS YOU HEARD- WE
PRODUCE THE CALIFORNIA DYSLEXIA
GUIDELINES. THAT HAVE BEEN USED
FOR TRAINING AND GUIDANCE FOR
THE FIELD AROUND DYSLEXIA WE-
HAVE REALIZED THROUGH THAT AND
WE KNEW THIS WAS ALREADY THAT
WE DO NEED A LOT MORE TRAINING
AND CAPACITY BUILDING. AROUND
THE ISSUES. ROUNDED BOXY AND
SPECIFIC LEARNING DISABILITIES
AND WE KNOW THAT IF WE CAN-
HELP STUDENTS LEARN TO READ.
PRIOR TO THEM HAPPENING TO READ
I LEARNED THAT I WILL BE A MUCH
BETTER POSITION AS THE STATE.
THE SO WE'RE- SUPPORTIVE AND
LOOK FORWARD TO DOING THE WORK
AGAIN ACROSS GENERAL AT THIS IS
NOT JUST THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
INITIATIVE IN OUR MIND WE HAVE
A DYSLEXIA EXPERT THAT'S
ACTUALLY IN OUR CURRICULUM
FRAMEWORKS DIVISION THAT WORKS
OUT OF GENERAL ED BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT IT'S SOMETHING THAT-
EVERY GENERAL EDUCATION.
TEACHER NEEDS TO BE ARMED WITH
IS THAT GOOD. THOSE GOOD
PRACTICES AROUND READING
INSTRUCTION AROUND DYSLEXIA.
GOOD ANYTHING ELSE WELL I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING MORE ABOUT
THIS INITIATIVE THANK YOU FOR
PRESENTING. THANK YOU ALL. FOR
OBVIOUSLY I HAVE NO QUESTION
SURPRISE SURPRISE. THE STATE.
WELL LET'S TAKE UP PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIS POINT IF YOU
WOULD QUEUE UP. AS I REFILL.
YOU KNOW MAY TWENTY FIVE CUPS A
DAY. OKAY PUBLIC COMMENT YOUR
FIRST MA'AM YES THANK YOU THE
ON YOUR OWN A GOOD MORNING I'M
WHISKEY AND WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES ARE WE WANT TO THANK
GOVERNOR NEWSOME AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION FOR KEEPING THE
COMMITMENT AND OUR EQUITY
FUNDING FORMULA IN L. CFL.
HONORING PROP NINETY EIGHT IN
THIS WAY IS NOT A GIVEN AND WE
APPRECIATE IT AND AS WE'VE ALL
OF KNOWLEDGE TODAY OUR PUBLIC
ED SYSTEM IS NOT FUNDED
ADEQUATELY FOR THE TASK OF
MEETING THE NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS FROM THE NUMBER OF
PROPERLY PREPARED ADULTS TO
PROVIDING THE BASIC CONDITIONS
OF LEARNING. LIKE THE OTHER
PUBLIC SERVANTS IN CALIFORNIA
THE DEBT WE OWE SCHOOL STAFF IN
RETIREMENT BENEFITS SHOULD NOT
BE PAID OUT OF THE SCARES
FUNDING SOURCE WE CARVE OUT FOR
EDUCATION BUT FROM THE GENERAL-FUND THE STATE COLLECTS ALL
CALIFORNIANS. SINCE I'LL SEE
ABOUT IT HAS BECOME PAINFULLY
CLEAR THAT THE STATE HAS BEEN
SUFFICIENT. FOR ON PREPARING A
DEVELOP TEACHER. WE IDENTIFIED.
AS A STATE PRIORITY BUT WE
DIDN'T FUNDED AT THE STATE
LEVEL WHEN IT'S CLEAR THAT
DISTRICTS ALONE CANNOT CREATE
AND MAINTAIN A STRONG EDUCATOR
WOKFORCE. THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSALS TO IMPROVE OUR
TEACHER WORKFORCE. ARE ROUTE
ISSUES IN OUR OPINION TO
ADDRESSING OUR OPPORTUNITY AN
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS. FOR OUR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS STUDENTS OF
COLOR IMMIGRANT STUDENTS.
THEY'RE THE ONES WHO BEAR THE
BRUNT OF AN ADEQUATELY FUNDED.
TEACHERS AND ARE FOR WORKFORCE
GETTING AND KEEPING HIGH
QUALITY SCHOOL STAFF TO THEIR
SCHOOLS SHOULD BE THE FOCUS OF
THE STATE'S EFFORTS WE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS THANKS FOR JOINING US
JUST MA'AM CAN REALLY
ROSENBERGER WITH SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
I'LL DOES HAVE A HIGH PLACE TO
HAVE A RATHER LONG PAPER- AS A
LOT OF OUR PRIORITIES- ARE
SIMILAR TO WHAT THE GOVERNOR
HAPPEN TARGETED FUNDING BUT WE
HAVE A FEW SUGGESTIONS- WE WERE
DISAPPOINTED NOT TO STEVE
MARTIN IS. THERE A SPECIAL
NEEDS STUDENT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING ARE CURRENTLY SCHOOLS
ARE PAYING THAT OUT OF THE
BABIES AND SO WE HAVE SEEN THE
LC ABOUT THE CAMPUS BY THE BASE
OFF BECAUSE OF IT BEING
CATALYZED. BY SPECIAL EDUCATION
SO I PUT IT OR IS THERE WE FEEL
FREE UP FOR OTHER EXPENDITURES
WE ALSO WOULD URGE THAT SOME OF
THOSE TRAINING DOLLARS GO TO
PARA PROFESSIONALS. OF WHAT WAS
NOTED BY WHEN THE PANELISTS
HAVE A CONTRACT OUT. SOME OF
THAT ASSISTANCE FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION. PROFESSIONALS
BASICALLY RECEIVED A FROM
TRAINING OR SEARCH. SO WE COULD
DO THAT HOUSE EVEN DOLLARS IN
THE LONG AND I'M ALSO WE WANT
TO. THE EFFORT I PERSONAL
SPENDING ACCESS AND TRAINING
FOR PARA PROFESSIONALS AND
CLASSIFIED WE ENCOURAGE AT THE
STATE IN AND I FINALLY
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT TO US- WE WERE
DISAPPOINTED NOT TO COUNTY
SERVICES HIGHLIGHTED AS A
PRIORITY AS- ELIGIBILITY
WORKERS WERE THE CORE OF THE
REGIONAL COMMUNITY. WELL ENSURE
THAT FAN TO GET IMMEDIATE.
ABILITY OLD AND HOW HOW FRESH
SSI THANK YOU. THANK YOU. YES
SIR. BUT AFTERNOON A TEHRAN RAP
WITH. FED OF T. THIS YOU HAVE
TO USE OF. PHYLLIS THE GOVERNOR
SEVERAL BUDGET FRAMEWORK THERE
ARE A LOT OF GREAT IDEAS IN
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL- THERE'S
ALSO TREMENDOUS NEED THERE ARE
SEVERAL THINGS THAT WE DO
SUPPORT SPECIFICALLY THAT IS.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION. AS SOME OF THE IDEAS
RELATED TO RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION INCREASING
INVESTMENTS IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION. OUR NUMBER ONE
PRIORITYIS TO SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE THE BASE FUNDING FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT WILL TAKE
SOME TIME. AND IN ORDER FOR THE
FOR THAT TO HAPPEN- THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
NEED TO GET SERIOUS ABOUT
RAISING ADDITIONAL REVENUE-
SPECIFIC TO THIS BUDGET WE
WOULD SUPPORT- INCREASING THE
COLA TO PRIDE. PROVIDED IF-
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. WILL ALSO SUPPORT-
INCREASING INVESTMENTS IN
PAYING DOWN PENSION
LIABILITIES. RELATED TO THE ONE
TIME FUNDING- YOU KNOW SOME OF
THE PROPOSALS AND THE TEACHER
RETENTION AND RECRUITMENT AREA.
ARE ARE ADMIRABLE PROPOSALS BUT
I SAY LET'S FIND WHAT WORKS AND
YOU BROUGHT THIS UP YOU SAID.
WHERE'S THE EVIDENCE BASICALLY-
THERE A COUPLE OF PROPOSALS WE
KNOW ARE WORKING WELL THAT'S A
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
TEACHER CREDENTIALING PROGRAM
WE SUPPORT THAT. THE APPLE
PROGRAM WHICH THE FALL. WE PORT
AT AND- COULD CAN YOU FIND OUT.
JEFF TEAGUE SO THOSE AREOUR
COMMENTS THANK YOU SIR THANKS
FOR JOINING US YES SIR. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR JORDAN LINDSAY
WITH THE ARE CALIFORNIA THE ARE
THE ARE CAN UNITED CIVIL PULLS
A CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION. IS
A SIXTEEN YEAR OLD YOUNG MAN IN
MENDOTA WHICH IS OUTSIDE OF
FRESNO HE HAS DOWN SYNDROME. HE
IS UNABLE TO SPEAK. N. HE
RECEIVES FIVE HOURS A SEMESTER
SPEECH THERAPY. HE REGRESSED IN
HIS SPEECH ABILITY HE'S NOW
REGRETS IN IN IN HIS PHYSICAL
ABILITY BECAUSE THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT LEASE IT IS EASIER. TO
PUT HIM IN A WHEELCHAIR TO GO
AROUND THE SCHOOL RATHER THAN
PER- SO PROVIDE SUPPORTS FOR
HIS PHYSICAL NEEDS. TO BE
INCLUSIVE IN THE SCHOOL. I
BRING UP HIS SPECIFIC STORY
BECAUSE THIS IS HAPPENING
EVERYWHERE ACROSS THE STATE THE
GOVERNOR SAID IN HIS JANUARY
BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT SPECIAL
EDUCATION IS IN CRISIS. AND HE
SAID HE DOES NOT USE THAT WORD
LIGHTLY I WOULD LIKE TO
UNDERSCORE THE GOVERNOR'S WORDS
ON THAT. ODENSE WITH AUTISM
MARIN BUSES FOR AN HOUR THERE
AND AN HOUR BACK TWO HOURS A
DAY BEING TRANSPORTED SHIP FROM
ONE DISTRICT TO ANOTHER THAT'S
HAPPENING ALTHOUGH ALL ACROSS
THE STATE. WE ARE FAILING THE
REQUIREMENT OF LEAST
RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENT AS YOU
FORTY DISCUSSED. INCLUSION IS
STILL JUST A CONCEPT THE THEORY
FIRST TOO MANY IN OUR STATE. I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW ITEMS
HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED TODAY IN
THAT THE ARK OF CALIFORNIA
WOULD LIKE TO SEE MOVE FORWARD.
FIRST WE SUPPORT YOUR COMMENTS
ABOUT ONE TIME PER SONG GOING
FUNDS. ONETIME DOES NOT ALLOW
FOR A LONG TIME LONG TERM
PLANNING. SECOND THERE MUST BE
GREATER CONSISTENCY OF MONTHS
DISTRICTS. TOO MANY DISTRICTS
ARE TREATING FAMILIES LIKE
PLAINTIFFS DURING IEP MEETINGS
AND YOU ASKED ABOUT IF THEY
HAVE MONEY IN THEIR SPINNING
INTO WIRED WHAT IS THE ISSUE
YOUR SUMMER SPENDING MONEY ON
NEW SEGREGATED. SCHOOL OF ROOMS
NEW SEGREGATED AT TRAILERS IN
THE BACK OF THE PARKING LOT
RATHER THAN SPEND IT ON IT
INCLUSION OF INDIVIDUALS IN
THIS IN THE CLASSROOMS. THERE
HAS TO BE GREATER AVAILABILITY
OF TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ASK US WHEN WE
CONFRONT THEM ABOUT VARIOUS
ISSUES WILL HELP US HOW DO WE
DO THIS BETTER THAT'S NOT OUR
ROLE. BUT THERE NEEDS TO BE
GREATER AVAILABILITY FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND WE
HIGHLY SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL FOR
ADDITIONAL PASSED TO DIPLOMAS
IN ALL OUR CONVERSATIONS IN A
WORK FOR THE DEPARTMENT RE HAVE
BEEN DDS BUT- MOVING FORWARD.
AFTER GRADUATION OR AFTER HIGH
SCHOOL CAN BE ONE OF THE MOST
SINGLE LARGEST FACTORS OF AN
INDIVIDUAL'S ABILITY TO KICK
COMPETITIVE IMMIGRANT PLACEMENT
AND THEIR ABILITY TO HAVE
INCLUSIVE- OPPORTUNITIES MOVING
FORWARD THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR PAM GIVES
REPRESENT THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
FIRST OF ALL WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S CONSISTENT.
INVESTMENTS IN EDUCATION BOTH
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT AND
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
MICHAEL IS CONSISTENTLY
SUPPORTED INCREASING THE TARGET
FOR LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA SO WE SUPPORT. ANY
EFFORTS BY THE LEGISLATURE TO
DO THAT WE ALSO SUPPORT ONE
TIME FUNDING THAT. IS IN AREAS
THAT HAVE SHOWN SUCCESS FOR
STUDENTS WHO ARE NOT BENEFITING
FROM THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA AS TESTIFIED TO EARLIER
TODAY. WE ARE ALSO ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH THESE A STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND. ON
AT ADDRESSING THE ACHIEVEMENT
GAP AND WE BELIEVE IT COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS INITIATIVE CAN DO THAT.
LAKE HAS A PILOT PROJECT RIGHT
NOW THAT WE'RE WORKING ON WE
HAVE A LINE OUR GOALS AND
GUIDING PRINCIPLES ALONG WITH
THE LEARNING POLICY INSTITUTE.
AND WE'RE ALSO BEING EVALUATED
ON THOSE PROGRAMS SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU WE
ALSO- ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO ADDRESS THE MEDICAL NEEDS-
OF SCHOOLS AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE PART OF THE WORK GROUP
AS EDUCATION. TO ENSURE FUNDING
IS A TO SCHOOLS OR THERE MAY
AND MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS. SO
THERE'S PLAY MORE THE GOVERNOR
DID INCLUDE. A SPECIALLY
PATIENT IN. OTHER THAT WE FOR
WITH YOU KNOW THAT IS AN OVER
MANY HEARING BUT- FOR TO
WORKING WITH YOU THROUGHOUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RIGHT. THIS.
HI THIRTY SIX YEAR HALF OF THE
SUPER IN FOR ME SO WE ALREADY
SUBMITTED A LETTER WITH OR
BUDGET PRIORITIES BUT JUST ONE
UNDER BASS ON TODAY'S DISCUSS
WE DO SO THE GUY AND WORK ABOUT
ON THESE AND WILL HAVE BEEN TO
ALL OUR SO EMERGE COUNTY BUT
STILL THROUGHOUT STATE WE ARE
HOW HERE FROM AND MORE OF OUR
DAYS ABOUT THERE'S PRESSURES
PRIMARILY DUE TO INCREASE
RELATE DEPEND AND ALSO IT A- WE
HAVE. THE ROBUST ABOUT THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION DOLLARS ONE
TIME VERSUS ON GOING- SO WE DO
ASK AS THESE CONVERSATIONS
CONTINUED TO KEEP THAT IN MIND
THE BALANCE BETWEEN ONE TIME
DOLLARS AN ON GOING DOLLARS
THAT WE CAN- BETTER SUPPORTER
DISTRICTS NOT ONLY IN
ADDRESSING ADDRESSING THE
TEACHER SHORTAGE BUT ALSO THEIR
BOTTOM LINE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM. YES MA'AM THEY'RE ABOUT
JUST WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL BUSINESS
OFFICIALS VERY APPRECIATIVE
THAT YOU BEGAN THE DOC
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR TOP
PRIORITY SPECIAL EDUCATION THIS
IS IN THEIR AREA AND STUDENTS
TO HAVE NOT BEEN RECOGNIZED FOR
A LONG TIME SO WE TRULY
APPRECIATE THAT WE BEGAN WITH
THIS CRITICAL COM. WE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE IN MAKING SURE THAT
WE CAN IN IN A OVER ALL WITH
WHICH RANK AT THE THIRTY NINTH
IN THE I ALSO SEND TO YOUR STAY
ADDRESSING THE QUESTIONS THAT
YOU IS THAT THE BEGIN REGARD
ITEM. TO TEACHER SHOWS UP TO A
RECENT BY CHILDREN NOW TITLED
NOT AN ADULTS IN A ROW. AT
TWENTY UNFORTUNATELY FIFTH AND
THE NEED IN IN TEACHER. STUDENT
RATIO AND FOR SEVENTH AND THEN
MAY. WHICH TEACH BE SHOW AND SO
FOR CASBAH WE WERE THE FIRST
SIDE OF THE- WE ARE FOR UP. THE
TECH. TO THIS. ACCOUNTANTS HR
SO THOSE. AT THE FOR TO THAT
KIND THAT IS ME. OUTSIDE OF. TO
OFFER A CHILDREN BECAUSE WE
NEED A SINGLE. TURN THAT WE PER
THE NEST RE. SUPPORT AN
INSTRUCTION. AS WELL AS SEE.
THE THANK YOU THANK YOU. YES
MA'AM HI GOOD MORNING AFTER AND
BALL HERE ON BEHALF OF SAN
GROUPS. THE ASSOCIATE OF CAL. A
SUBURBAN SCHOOL DOES. A GROUP
OF DISTRICTS AND COUNTIES SIX
ACCOUNT IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AND THE ORANGE COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF ED. SO FAR
OVERVIEW COMMENTS WE WANT TO
SAY WE APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE'S CONTINUED
COMMITMENT TO LCF ASK. YOU
REYES REALLY GOOD POINTS WE ARE
ABOUT DISTRICTS FISCAL
PRESSURES SO ALL OF THESE
GROUPS THROUGHOUT THE STATE ARE
LOOKING FOR AT LEAST AN
INCREASE COLA AN INCREASE IN
THE BASE GRANT. ON SPECIAL AT
RE REALLY APPRECIATE THIS
CONVERSATION AND SEND A RAFI
YOU ASKED. A LOT OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT WE HAVE ABOUT
THE PRE SCHOOL FUNDING
ESPECIALLY. A PRESCHOOL SPECIAL
NEEDS CHILDREN WE NEED ON GOING
FUNDING TO REALLY MAKE THE
INVESTMENTS AND THE CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT TO REALLY BUILD
PROGRAMS TO SERVE THE STUDENTS.
ONE THING THESE GROUPS ALSO
AGREE ON THAT I WOULD JUST WANT
TO CALL OUT ON PAGE SEVENTEEN
AT THE BOTTOM OF YOUR- HAND OUT
OF YOUR AGE. AND THAT WE REALLY.
THE GOVERNOR'S ALSO TO EXPAND
THE USE OF THE F. FUNDING FOR
WHAT IS NOW. EDUCATIONALLY
RELATED MENTAL HEALTH FUNDING
ABOUT THREE IT'S ON THE LA-
HAND OUT IT'S ALMOST FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
SOME DISTRICTS THAT ARE HAVING
CHALLENGES. EXPANDING THAT
BECAUSE OF THE RESTRICTIONS.
THE TRAILER BILL PROPOSES TO
EXPAND THAT TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES BEYOND THOSE REQUIRED
BY NINETY P. AND I KNOW YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE A HEARING LATER THIS
MONTH ON MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP LAST YEAR. ALL THOSE
DISTRICTS THAT I MENTION IN
THOSE GROUPS ARE VERY
INTERESTED IN CONTINUED FUNDING
FOR THAT SO. WE LOOK FORWARD
TO. ENGAGING WITH YOU. FURTHER
THANK THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION YES SIR. HELLO MY
HARD TO FOLLOW. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRPERSON YOUR RISE.
WHEN YOU'RE SO THEY WERE WITH
YOU KNOW A CAL FOR AND FOREMOST
I WANT TO THINK COMMITTEE AS
WELL AS YOU FOR COMING. VERY
GOOD AND APPRECIATIVE OF THE
BUDGET PROPOSALS AND WE'RE VERY.
THEY SAID YOU HAVE ANY DEVELOP
OR THE CA WEEKS MONTHS YOU KNOW
WAYS IN OUR- LOOK. TO TECHNICAL
WITH. HI TO ALL DEEP CAN
CONNECT. ON WHAT WORKS SIX
PUBLIC SCHOOL PUBLIC'S STUDENTS.
ESPECIALLY THOSE THE THREE POP
IN TRAUMA. WE WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
IN THIS CON. ESPECIALLY WERE
THINKING. COMMUNITY SCHOOLS AN
OPPORTUNITY GRANTS THE WORLD
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
PLAY IN WRAPPING STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES AND SERVICES. AND AT
HAVING TO NECESSARILY IDENTIFY
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS FOR DIRECT
SERVICES. RATHER TAPPING INTO
THE COMMUNITY SUPPORTS THAT
ALREADY EXIST. AND THE
WILLINGNESS OF PARTNERS IN THE
PUBLIC PRIVATE SECTOR TO WRAP
THE STUDENTS AND FAMILIES IN
THOSE SUPPORT. JUST AS IT AS
THE DECAY. IS A- THE- OUTSIDE
OF. THAT IMPACT CHILDREN'S OF
TO AND SIX. WE DO BELIEVE THAT
INVESTMENTS LIKE COMMUTER
SCHOOLS AND HEALTHY STAR OF THE
WAY TO GET TARGETED AND
INTENTIONAL. TO REALLY ADDRESS
OPPORTUNITY AND ACHIEVING GAPS
AND WE'RE EAGER TO CONTINUE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. YOU ROSE TO THE
CHALLENGE OR- YES MA'AM GOOD
AFTERNOON JANICE CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE FUND CALIFORNIA I THINK
YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR YOUR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF SO MANY
PROGRAMS THAT WILL BENEFIT THE
MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN IN OUR
STATE. I'D LIKE TO ALIGN MY
COMMENTS WITH BOTH OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM UNITED WAYS AND
JUST ADD OUR OVERALL EXCITEMENT
ABOUT THE EFFORTS TO PROVIDE
SERVICES AND SCHOOLS
PARTICULARLY IN MENTAL HEALTH
AND TRAUMA INFORMED CARE. I AM
WE BELIEVE IT'S ESSENTIAL AND
WHEN YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS THE PROGRAMS
ARE DEVELOPED WITH LOCAL
FLEXIBILITY AND CONNECTIONS
WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE MY COLLEAGUE
MENTIONED I'M AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
AROUND ON GOING SUSTAINABILITY
EFFORTS IN DISCUSSING TO
PROVIDE FOR OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN OVER THE LONG HAUL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SIR THE
SYDNEY BUT POSSIBLE GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIR MONEY IS
MUCH WORSE I'M HERE THE COUNCIL
DEVELOPMENT THIS. THE COUNCIL
SUPPORTS THE NEED TO ENSURE
ROBUST FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION IS AVAILABLE WE
BELIEVE THAT EVERY STUDENT
SHOULD RECEIVE A QUALITY
EDUCATION WITH THEIR PEERS THAT
WILL PREPARE THEM FOR POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION AND OR
MEANINGFUL EMPLOYMENT THE CORE
COMPONENT US BELIEVE IS
ADEQUATE FUNDING WE SUPPORT THE
IDEA THAT TO ENSURE STUDENTS
RECEIVE FREE APPROPRIATE PUBLIC
EDUCATION IN THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENT.
TEACHERS SCHOOL LEADERS AND
OTHER PROFESSIONALS MUST HAVE
ACCESS TO PROPER PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT NAMELY TRAINING AND
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT THEIR USE
OF VALID POSITIVE IN PROACTIVE
PRACTICES IN TEACHING
STRATEGIES THE STATE COUNCIL
LOOKS FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE CD IMPROVE INCLUSIVE
EDUCATION OUTCOMES. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHELLE MCKAY
UNDERWOOD ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE FUNDING
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION- YOU HAVE
OUR BUDGET LETTER SO I'LL JUST
HIT THE HIGHLIGHTS- WE ARE ONCE
AGAIN VERY GRATEFUL TO BE
HAVING A CONVERSATION ABOUT
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES FOR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES OR
SO MANY YEARS- ONE THAT JUST
WASN'T PART OF THE CONVERSATION
AND PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET SO WE DEFINITELY
APPRECIATE THAT. EIGHT HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE DOLLARS OF ALL.
SOURCES WE DO THINK THOUGH THAT
A LOT OF THE GOALS THAT WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT TODAY CAN BE
ACHIEVED THROUGH THE CURRENT
FUNDING FORMULA. AND UPDATING-
UPDATING THAT THE FUNDING
FORMULA THAT'S CURRENTLY IN
PLACE THINK THAT YOU KNOW WHILE
THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS BASED ON SCORES BUT
THIS IS. HIS LAST YEAR WELCOME
WE BELIEVE THAT NEEDS TO BE ON
RESEARCH. BE THOSE ARE ON PROBE
DUTCH BE ADDED TO FOR HALF
THOSE PROGRAMS SPECIAL WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE LARGEST
MOVE THIS YEAR TO START THE
CONVERSATION. AND MAKE STEP.
FOR TWENTY. SIX NINETY FIVE
MILLION OR SO THE GOVERNOR'S.
WE CAN GO REALLY FOR. OUT GET
ABOUT NOW 5% OF. CHIEF FOR.
WITH THIS. IN THE STATE AND
THEN. WHAT'S I THINK MISSING
SOMETIMES FROM THE COMPUTATION
IS THE FOCUS ON. STUDENTS WITH
MORE SEVERE DISABILITIES- THE
LA- HAS HIGHLIGHTED THE FACT
THAT WE'VE HAD A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE- IN THAT POPULATION OF
COURSE WITH THE MORE NEEDS- IS
MORE COSTLY SERVICES TO. MAKE
SURE THAT THEY HAVE AN
APPROPRIATE MEDICATION SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S
PART OF THE CONVERSATION AS
WELL AND WE- LOOK FORWARD TO.
HAVING THAT CONVERSATION IN THE
TRANSPARENCY BUDGET PROCESS
THIS YEAR. THANKS SO MUCH
THANKS FOR JOINING US. YES
MA'AM. HELLO CHAIR BUT
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RUNNING A
CODES I AM THE ASSISTANT
SUPERINTENDENT FOR TO HIM A
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
AND HUMAN COUNTY SULFA THEY
REPRESENT FIFTEEN ELEAZAR
RANGING FROM THIRTY ATA WE
ACTUALLY HAVE. A ONE ROOM
SCHOOLHOUSE STILL IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. UP TO TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. SO I APPRECIATE IT
MANY OF YOUR QUESTIONS TO THE
PANEL THROUGHOUT THE DAY ABOUT
WHY ARE WE TALKING ABOUT THIS
GOVERNMENT GOVERNANCE TIED TO
FISCAL. THERE IS. THE INTEREST
IS IN THOSE US IN THE NORTH WHO
HAVE NO. SMALL AND- THE- BUT
EIGHT. ONE FROM. THIRTY EIGHT.
NEED ALL OF THAT GOVERNOR TO
GET TO. GERALD FINANCIAL. SO I
URGE ALL OF THIS. I'M
COMMITTEES AND WERE GROUPS TO
ALSO HAVE NECESSARY SMALL.
SMALL AND SPARSE AS IN NOT CALM.
WE HAVE ANY OF THOSE IN THE
STATE. I AM I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO LINE MY- WITH WETNESS. UNDER
WHAT SET AS WELL AS THE
COALITION FOR. FUND FOR
SPECIALTY. I ALSO THOUGHT.
REALLY AGREED WITH YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT THE ONE. WHO
MANY. THINK THAT IS CRITICAL TO
BE TALKING ABOUT. IN A- IN THE
PHOTO RURAL SOUTH BY THAN THOSE
RURAL. ELIA IS SPECIFICALLY
MINE WE ONLY HAVE FIVE LED. ARE
THINGS WE NEED TO CONTINUE
TALKING ABOUT. AS WELL AS
CONTINUING TO HAVE- THE WORLD
INVOLVED BECAUSE WE ARE OUT
THERE. THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
COMING DOWN TO JOIN US. YES
MA'AM GOOD ACTORS MY NAME'S
ELIZABETH ANGLE CAN AND I'M THE
ASSISTANT SUPERINTENDENT FOR
YOLO COUNTY RIGHT HERE TO THE
WEST- I WAS VERY IMPRESSED WITH
HANDLES QUESTIONS AND VERY
PLEASED TO HEAR OF THE FOCUS ON
ENHANCE FUNDING FOR STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES I REPRESENTS
THIS SIX SUPERINTENDENTS WHO
ARE LOOKING AT WAYS TO
IMPLEMENT INCLUSIVE PRACTICES
BECAUSE OF A LITTLE MORE
FLEXIBILITY IN THEIR BUDGET
THIS YEAR- WE DO SUPPORT
STRONGLY SUPPORTED ON GOING
FUNDING FOR OUR PRE SCHOOL
STUDENTS. IN A SELF A WITH
VARIOUS SIZE- ELEAZAR AS MISS
COATS MENTIONED WE HAVE VERY
SMALL DISTRICTS THAT ARE VERY
RELIANT ON A PRESCHOOL STRUCK
OF SEVEN LARGER. AND TO HAVE
THAT FUNDING MODEL CONTINUE FOR
THEM WOULD MAKE A GREAT
DIFFERENCE IN THEIR ABILITY TO
PROVIDE SERVICES. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. YES SIR BOB GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR STAFF-
INTO GARAGE WITH THE SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND WE
SEND OUT OUR LETTER THIS
MORNING SO I JUST STICK TO THE
HIGHLIGHTS- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR QUESTIONS TODAY BOB
SAN DIEGO UNIFIED SHARES THE
MANY OF THE GOALS IDENTIFIED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET-
BUT WE DO HAVE DEEP CONCERNS
AND JUST THE OVERALL SENSE OF
URGENCY IN THE WAY THE-
PROPOSALS ARE STRUCTURE AND HOW
THAT WOULD AFFECT OUR FINANCIAL
PLANNING. I AND SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WERE FOCUSED ON FOUR
KEY RECOMMENDATIONS THE FIRST
ONE I KNOW HAS BEEN BROUGHT UP
ALREADY- IT'S AN ALLOCATION
BASED ON THE MODERATE TO SEVERE
THE ABILITY OF STUDENTS IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION A SECOND
RAISING THE COLA- I KNOW THE
MOTEL YOUR PROJECTIONS THEY WE
USED AYE AYE 3% HAS SAYS WITH
THE REDUCTION OF SIX POINT
SEVEN MILLION I AT FIRST TRUMP
SO THAT IS A CONCERN FOR US. AT
THIRTY A PET SAID WELL NOT. I
AM FINE FINALLY AGAIN AGREE WE
MANY OTHER GOALS I. WITH SOME
OF THESE COMPETITIVE GRANTS BUT
WE BELIEVE THAT WE CAN BETTER
AND MORE DIRECTLY SERVE
STUDENTS IF THEY'RE MADE
AVAILABLE ON AND ABA BASIS
STATEWIDE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR NEXT YES SIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR I'M JAKE
BREMNER WITH THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY- HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CAMPAIGN AS WELL
AS OUR PARTNERS AT ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE AND
DOZENS OF OTHER CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE.
THEY PARTICIPATE IN THE COLLEGE
FOR ALL COALITION- AS YOU MIGHT
RECALL IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE
STATE ALLOCATED SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES TO HELP HIGH SCHOOL
SERVING THE MOST HIGH NEED
STUDENTS- IMPROVE HOW THEY CAN
HELP THE STUDENTS BECOME
ELIGIBLE. FOR COLLEGE AND
PURSUE HIGHER EDUCATION IN THE
TIME SINCE THEN WE'VE SEEN
DISTRICTS ASPECT OF WE USE
THESE FUNDS TO EXPAND ACCESS
DAVID G. CURRICULUM INCREASE
THE COUNSELING SERVICES
AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES AS WELL AS COVER FEES
FOR THE EIGHTY OR- OR COLLEGE
ADMISSIONS EXAMS- AND WHAT
WE'VE SEEN IMPROVEMENTS-
UTILIZING THESE BONDS. RACIAL
EQUITY GAPS ARE PERSISTENT AND-
OUR HIGH SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA
CONTINUE TO ONLY GRADUATE 37%
OF LATINO MALES AND ONE THIRD
OF BLACK MALES AS COLLEGE
READY. SO WE STILL HAVE
SIGNIFICANT EQUITY GAPS THAT
REQUIRE CONTINUED INVESTMENT
AND FOCUS ON THE PART OF THE
STATE AND I KNOW I SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE CAMPAIGN AS WELL
AS OUR PARTNERS AT THE
COALITION WHEN WE EXPRESS OUR
GRATITUDE FOR THIS BODY
SUPPORT. FOR THE CALL TRADING
THIS BLOCK GRANT THIS YEAR ARE
THIS PAST YEAR- AND HOPE THAT
WE CAN PARTNER IN THE COMING
MONTHS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET
A REINVESTMENT IN THE CULPRIT
IN THIS BLOCK GRANT IN THE
FINAL AND I. STATE BUDGET.
THANK YOU. YES SIR. AFTER
AFTERNOON ROTTEN STAFF GREG
KRAMER WITH THIS BILL RIGHTS
CAL DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA'S GENERALLY SUPPORT
OF THE BUDGET BUT WE BELIEVE
THAT ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS
NECESSARY TO ENSURE STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES RECEIVE
ADEQUATE SERVICES I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO A LINE- WITH THAT MR
LINDSEY'S COMMENTS REGARDING
THE BARRIERS TO INCLUSION THAT
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITY
CURRENTLY FACE AND- WE LOVE THE
EFFORTS IMPROVING ACCESS TO
DIPLOMAS AND- VALUE THE
COMMITMENT TO BETTER TRAIN
TEACHERS AND STAFF- REGARDING
TEACHER AND STAFF TRAINING I
WOULD BELIEVE THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ROLL UP WITHIN TWO
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS- DE
ESCALATION TRAINING AND
ALTERNATIVES TO RESTRAIN
SECLUSION WHICH-
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS
PUPILS OF. COLOR AND- DOUBLES
WHAT DISABILITY AND WE LOOK FOR
TO CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS ON
SPECIAL AT FUNDING THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND
THANKS FOR PARTICIPATING ANY
OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT. SEEING
NONE THIS- HEARING OF BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE IS
ADJOURNED.